Sweet baby.
Jesus.
Here we go again.
Did Jesus people get upset?
Have you?
Sweet Baby Jesus and like a nice way
because I know they get pissed.
If you say Jesus fucking Christ,
they don't like that.
No.
If you say sweet baby,
Jesus in the manger,
it's good.
It's all good.
How about if you only say sweet baby
Jesus in a nice way.
See Baby Jesus.
Sweet Baby Jesus.
Sexually sounding though like
pedophiles.
You're tasting Jesus.
Sweet.
You do.
Don't they do eat the flesh and drink
the blood anyway?
Yeah,
that got freaky.
He's responsible for basically any
creepy notions that people have just by
that,
even if that's true,
why tell people,
but keep the kid.
Give him some bread and wine,
which we barely believe he came back
from the dead.
All right,
we're supposed to eat you,
drink you.
This has nothing to do with anything.
This podcast is brought to you by
audible.com.
If you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
you can get one free month of audible
service and one free audio book.
What is audible?
Did you pay attention to the second
part?
Pitch?
I said audio book,
put it together for yourself.
What do you think audible is?
Well,
audible.com
is an amazing resource of thousands and
thousands of audio books.
It's really bad ass of your commuter.
Like we can only put out so many
podcasts and most likely,
if you're like me,
the reason why this podcast started a
half an hour late because we live in Los
Angeles and there's too many fucking
people here.
So you get stuck in your car and it
could either be frustrating or you can
listen to some cool shit.
Uh,
I was,
uh,
listening on the way up here to a
podcast so you can do that.
Or you can listen to audio books because
in podcast oftentimes,
especially if you read this,
listen to this one,
you're going to get a lot of information
that might not necessarily be true.
It also might not necessarily,
might not necessarily be able to be
pronounced.
It might not necessarily be good for
you.
We might tell you some shit just for a
goof.
Okay?
But if you get like a really good book,
at the very least you might learn
something.
There's a whisper sync,
which is one of my favorite new
applications.
It's really one of the coolest things
I've ever heard of and what it is for
audible.com.
It's an application that allows you to
download a book and a companion audio
book.
So say if you're at home reading your
book and you get to page 23 and then you
fall asleep when you get in your car,
you have it sync up through this whisper
sync,
a audible.com
application and it syncs up to your
smartphone and then when you get in your
car,
the version of the audio book picks up
where you left off.
It's fucking brilliant.
It is such a great idea and such a great
product and Ufford fantastic reviews of
this where people are super psyched,
so I'm more books are starting to put
those in a companion audio versions of
the book,
but you can get all of
them@aaudible.com.
Anything that has one of those,
a companion books
and look what they have all your
appearances on.
Opie and Anthony,
they have your cds.
They have a bunch of shit.
Yeah,
they have pretty much anything you could
ask for,
you know,
as far as like comedy as far as
interesting books,
books by our friends like well to do.
They have Tim Ferriss,
Tim Ferriss at war with them.
How's that work?
Because I know Tim Ferriss at war with
all the regular book dealers.
Right.
There was like a big issue that he had
there.
They're trying to barnes and noble.
Barnes and Bobo.
Why you fucking with our friend Tim
Ferriss?
You silly silly bitch.
I know.
Steven Pressfield is a great read of his
books.
I've listened to some of his own.
It's actually him reading it and talking
to you.
So
no,
those are perfect to recommend because
those are two of my favorite books of
all time turning pro,
which is the newest one.
Um,
and uh,
Steven Pressfield put out a book that
changed a lot of people's lives in the
creative business and it's called the
war of art.
And it deals with one thing that really
fucks with a lot of people and that's
procrastination,
procrastination and what he calls
resistance,
meaning that you're,
you're most happy when you get your work
done,
when you do the things you,
especially creatively that you want to
do.
But for a lot of us,
we struggle with this thing that makes
us fuck off and you know,
instead of doing what you're supposed to
do,
you beat off you email people you find,
you find shit to do,
to distract you.
And he details us and explains this.
And one of the clearest and most
beneficial ways I think I've ever heard
it described,
you'll be surprised you.
You read his book,
you feel like he's talking to you and be
like,
Steven,
what's up?
How'd you get in my head?
Because all of the things that prevent
you from doing what you could and what
you should do,
he's talking about the fears,
the doubts.
The procrastination is like you
mentioned all of that and gives it a
name resistance.
And once you name it,
then you can kill it.
It's like that Arnold Schwarzenegger
with a Predator once,
I believe it's.
You can kill it.
Yeah.
And the cool thing about pressfield
pressfield as a human being was
essentially a failure at the time he
started.
Got it all together when he was in his
forties.
It's really interesting because,
you know,
he's very,
very frank about his old habits and very
frank about his old work and you know,
what was wrong with the early part of
his,
his career as a writer and how he turned
it around.
And now it's hugely,
hugely respected and you know,
written huge selling books on history
has some screenplays that were turned
into movies like the legend of Bagger
Vance,
which probably isn't a good example
because it looked like a piece of shit.
Then it,
oh,
it's magical black guy that's good at
golf.
The fuck out of here,
Steven Pressfield,
but,
but turning pro in the more of our
excellent audible.com
forward slash Joe.
Go there,
you fuck and get it free for 30 days and
you get a free audio book.
And I would recommend the war of art
because it's fucking sensational.
And you said it's that right?
Uh,
it should be.
I've heard it on audio powerful,
audible and uh,
we're also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com.
And what a coincidence at all.
[inaudible] and is here buddy?
Well,
that's crazy.
Why don't you tell everybody about the
latest shit because every time I turn
around there's new stuff.
There's some Himalayan sea salt,
which is that a new better for you than
regular season Himalayan sea salt.
The deal with that is normal sea salt.
They artificially produce it and it's
sodium chloride.
It's artificially produced.
So it's not really coming from the
ocean.
Just bond the chemicals together.
And what happens is when they call that
sea salt sea salt,
but just regular table salt,
like what you'll find at your denny's
diner or whatever,
you know,
that kind of.
And what they did is they found that
people started getting mineral
imbalances when they created that and
having health problems,
particularly from the lack of iodine
that people were acquiring mostly from
their salt.
So that's why you get iodized salt
because they threw that back in there.
Like,
all right,
well at least give them iodine back,
but what they're missing is the 81 other
trace minerals that are found in a
natural salt.
The Himalayan salt,
so has about 80,
80 more minerals than regular salt.
It's a great source to get your mineral
content and in addition,
the reason why the Himalayan is most
preferred is because the deposits are
like $300,
million years old and that's before
there was pollution as before big old
ships dropped petroleum bombs into our
waters and polluted the sea salt and
everything like that.
It's just a really pristine deposit of
salt because it was back in the days
where there is just volcano.
No dinosaur.
Yeah,
that's it.
So you know,
Tara dactyl poo is like the.
That was the problem back then as far as
far as pollution.
So when you buy a biologist,
let's just be clear about this though.
When you buy sea salt though,
something says sea salt,
it has to come from the ocean.
Sea Salt is pretty good because we kind
of said that accidentally earlier you
were saying they make it,
but I think he just meant tables.
Table salt table,
salt table,
so the difference between sea salt and
Himalayan Sea salt is what?
It's just more nutritious.
It's nutrition as,
as lot of mineral content.
You can kind of see that in the pink,
that's the mineralization from it and so
a little bit more mineralization and a
more pristine deposit so.
And it tastes better too.
Once you start using it,
it doesn't have that sharp bite.
Salt has a real bite to it.
This just has the flavor of salt so you
can actually use a little bit more salt.
Do you use it when you grill?
I do,
so I use kosher salt.
That's what I've always used for
grilling.
We better really formula though.
I know what I'm doing now.
Just sobbing.
I'm I tried out this week now.
What about killer bee honey?
I don't.
Is that any better than regular honey or
is it just bad ass?
It's just bad.
Just how do they get this killer bees to
deposit this honey?
I mean,
isn't it dangerous to farm those
fuckers?
There'd be pimp,
hand strong.
Wow.
They
just keep them high when they're blowing
smoke.
That's not weed,
but it should be.
Wouldn't it be cool if.
I mean,
I think it's just smoke,
right?
The idea is the smoke confuses them and
calms them down.
So why wouldn't you use wheats monk?
I wonder if that would affect your
relationship with the bees.
I fall sudden the hive got super
creative and harmony and you could
control them and shit.
Making art project.
Maybe they stopped working for the Queen
and the whole thing we get fucked.
They would realize that I doing with
this queen bee is a cunt.
If they would realize like the queen bee
is the only be that can sting you and
not die.
Do you know why?
Because she uses that Stinger to murder
baby females.
That's why lemonade and competent,
she uses that Stinger and most of the
babies that die in the,
in the hive,
they die from wounds from the side wall
while the,
uh,
the female walks around a realizes
there's a female grown in there.
So she pulls out a tap in Paris Stinger
and just starts fucking up that baby
while its in the Walton the hive.
So think about that.
Vegans.
Vegans will need hunting strict vegans.
That's silly.
Now you said it is man,
but who are we?
Who are reading meet these bees work for
us man.
He's one of the things we were talking
about before the podcast and it's
fucking so legit.
I'm drinking this starbucks coffee and
man is it tastes like shit compared to
bulletproof coffee and I really do.
That is a mycotoxins.
Ladies and gentlemen is something that I
got alerted to by Dave asprey,
Dave asprey of bulletproof exec.com.
Fascinating guy with a lot of knowledge
when it comes to health and wellness and
a optimum living and he sells this stuff
called bulletproof coffee and what it is
is coffee from a single source that is
cultivated and maintained to be mold
free and you're like what do you mean
mold free?
Yeah.
That's something I didn't know about
either.
Most coffee that you buy has mold on it
and you know,
I'm tasting this right now and it tastes
pretty fucking shitty in comparison to
this bulletproof coffee because last
week I stopped drinking any regular
coffee and just went 100 per 100 percent
bulletproof and the mycotoxins like
really can affect you.
They affect your stomach,
they affect the way you feel after you
drink coffee.
Crash.
Yeah.
Fresh.
It's like it adds on.
It compels from the caffeine is going to
leave your system.
But the way that coffee has that kind of
savage crashed,
it feels like that's from the toxins.
Yeah.
I different coffee.
I feel very different.
That's really fucking disturbing to me
that starbucks is essentially selling
poison.
Who Don't sue me?
I'm just allegedly allegedly.
Why?
Listen to me.
What do I know?
I told you at the beginning,
I'm going to tell you a lot of false
shit,
but uh,
I would like to get it tested.
I mean,
we,
maybe we could do that.
Can we test our marks?
Can we go to like we probably get sued
if we did that.
We just didn't use her name.
We said we went to Dave's doing that
already.
Yes,
it's coming out.
We're actually,
he's comparing performance monitors for
both bulletproof and for starbucks,
so hopefully we'll get there.
How do you do that?
By a double blind placebo.
Someone's drinking bulletproof.
Someone's drinking regular and I'm
testing some things.
I don't think it's a double blind.
I think it's more of like an open ended
single arm research and doing something
like that.
Is You gonna name?
Starbucks coffee bean.
I said Shit.
Yeah.
That's where it gets troublesome.
Those fuckers,
they'll come after you,
but it would be nice if they didn't sell
coffee.
That was fucking bad for you.
You know,
I,
I didn't really know.
A lot of people when you drink coffee
and you feel like shit,
you don't really understand what's going
on,
but you are drinking poisonous fungus.
It sounds ridiculous and it sounds like
you wouldn't be hearing about that from
the fear factor guy feel like that would
be some shit that would be in the news.
That'd be some shit because so many
people go to starbucks.
That'd be some shit that we would know
about.
It is,
it's,
it's a,
it's real.
And uh,
this,
this thing exists,
not just in coffee but also in corn.
I've been researching mycotoxins online
after having that conversation with
them,
some disturbing shit.
Um,
but if you try out bulletproof coffee,
are we still selling it cheaper than
Dave asprey has,
is the same price.
No,
he didn't like that though.
You're selling cheaper than him,
but it's fantastic coffee and I swear to
you,
it is different in its effect on your
body and you really need to try it to,
to understand what the fuck is going on.
A stuff's not cheap,
but if you could find some other version
where you can be sure that it's a
microbe free,
I suggest go with that.
Then do whatever you can,
but get that shit out of your life like,
I'm not going to finish this because it
tastes fucking nasty.
Now I got a Venti starbucks.
I'm not going to finish it.
And that's how much an effect the
bulletproof coffee.
What Dave's formula for bulletproof
coffee is really fucking interesting and
what it is is coffee and then he takes
mct oil and mct oil is also something
that we sell it on it and mct oil is
coconut oil that gets thrown through a
centrifuge and it gets spun around like
wicked fast and they take it,
isolates the most nutritious aspect of
it.
And then they take that out and then he
adds this mct oil to the coffee along
with grass fed butter.
And you blend that bitch,
check it out,
throw a scoop of hemp force in there.
Go licious.
Delicious.
That is the secret.
The secret.
I'll remark as powerful move.
That's one scoop.
Try that.
About 12 grams.
Yeah.
Oh,
that sounds good.
And throw it in a blender.
You want to make sure your blender is
tight though.
[inaudible].
I had one of them,
uh,
old school blenders and I tried to make
bulletproof coffee and fucking shot off
the top and it was a mess.
The counter is a mess,
but there's a Blendtec blenders can
handle it.
Um,
and,
and you mix it all together and the
coffee is sensation that it's really
like some of the best tasting shit
you'll ever had in your life.
It's delicious.
It's like warm and it's like it's creamy
because it's got the grass fed butter in
it and oh,
it's really,
really good and I'm telling you will,
you will have a different effect and how
the caffeine and how uh,
how your body feels a after the coffee.
There's no big major crash like you'd
get with regular shit.
And uh,
I'm really interested to see what Dave
asprey's results are because I tend to
think that we're going to realize in a
couple of years from now,
like,
Holy Fuck,
we've been poisoning ourselves with
fungus.
I used to think a coffee and I think you
had somebody mentioned it to you,
but it was almost like a hard drug at
that point was you're going to take
coffee,
you know that there's going to be a
consequence down the.
But now you can drink it and I feel
consequence free.
It feels like,
okay,
okay.
Yeah,
sure.
I'll have some coffee.
No big deal.
As energetic as I did during the peak.
Yeah,
but I don't have that.
It's smoother,
goes on smoother and leaves me there.
I haven't had coffee before.
That makes me want to fall asleep.
Like you have a company like,
oh,
I just need to take a nap.
Just totally yawning and nodding out.
You're like,
what the fuck is in that coffee?
Poisoned fish.
Um,
what else?
Oh,
on its selling its own coconut oil now
labeled coconut oil that just got to my
house.
I'm like,
this is ridiculous.
Yeah.
So what we're doing here is it seems
like we're adding a lot of these random
things.
Basically what we're trying to do is
we're trying to create a comprehensive
program that can help people on the
supplement side,
on the fitness side,
and give them some key staple foods.
They can replace some of their other
poorer quality foods with like the salt,
like the coffee,
like the raw honey.
And the key about the killer bee honey
is it is raw and the way that you digest
that with the natural enzymes included
in the minerals way better for you than
process cooked honey.
So all of these different food sources
allow you to replace some other crap
that you have.
Tonka bars are natural buffalo and
cranberry bars,
you know,
take those and throw out your slim Jims
or whatever else you're snacking on.
It's just going to be a better
alternative.
So that way on the food side,
we know we're not going to have every
food,
your staple diet,
you're still gonna have to go out,
eat nutritious,
drink your Kale shakes,
do whatever you can,
but on some of the staples and some of
the additives that you're normally
putting in your diet,
we're helping to provide a better
alternative for that.
And then of course on the supplement
side,
we've all talked about that a lot,
but trying to create high performance,
highly densely packed nutritional
supplements around a certain issue,
you know,
brain mood,
sports,
um,
whatever we can think of that we can
pack together as many,
you know,
powerful ingredients in one formula and,
and provide that and next coming up,
which is still a little top secret.
We haven't released the details,
but we have our,
uh,
testosterone and performance supplement
coming up,
which I'm really stoked about.
A lot of people think that testosterone
supplements are bullshit and the reason
why they think that is because most of
them are bullshit.
But there are some things that can boost
your testosterone naturally.
Yeah.
And uh,
the beautiful Zma as one of them.
The beautiful thing about accompany,
like on it is you own the company so you
don't work for anybody.
So you can stock the store with cool
shit.
You don't have to like get it approved.
You know,
like I've had conversations with you,
like the blender conversation.
We had a conversation today,
man,
we should carry blenders.
Fuck out.
It's Carrie blenders,
boom.
What Carrie and blenders,
I mean it's really that easy.
I'm one of the things we talked about
that we haven't done anything about yet,
but we're talking about.
We're talking about an on it hunting
ranch.
We're talking about it and we're also
talking about we could start selling
that meat,
frozen grass fed meat,
frozen grassfed,
venison and selling it to people.
The idea being that if you eat meat and
I eat a lot of meat,
I want to be responsible at least
somewhat for how that animal lives and
if we decide to start selling grassfed
venison,
there's a couple different ways to do it
and one of them is if you have a high
fence operation,
which is in Texas,
they have a lot of branches now.
Thousands and thousands of acres.
They put a big fence around it and
there's deer that live inside there and
you.
You basically set up tree stands,
you wait for one to catch up,
slipping,
and you blast them.
Well,
once you do that,
you can do whatever you want with that
meat.
You can eat that meat or you could sell
it online if we set up a place like that
where we can take people on their first
hunting adventure,
like literally like bring people to a
place where you'll allow them to kill
their own meat and doing it in a humane
and safe way,
but do it also in a way where you're
relatively insured of success,
but this animal is living a complete
natural life before you come along and
pop a cap in his ass.
Yeah,
being directly hands on with your food
source,
knowing what it's eating,
knowing what you're eating and being
playing a role in that.
I mean,
that's a part of the birthright of
humanity.
Not only is it good for your health,
it's going to be,
I think,
important for your spirit if you're
eating meat that somebody else's killing
your whole life without actually going
through the process.
Something a little weird about that.
Yeah.
And there's a lot of people have a
disconnect from their food and uh,
the idea is that if you,
if we had a place where you could go and
it would have to be very large,
large enough where it doesn't feel like
you're shooting deer in the backyard
because that's the big knock on these
high fence operations.
It's canned hunting.
Um,
but really what it is,
is like if it's a large enough piece of
property management,
you're managing the population of the
animals and your manager from other
people.
Yeah.
You procure,
you're procuring food and you're
essentially like,
you're harvesting these animals in a way
way different than farming.
Like if we started our own grass fed
cattle operation,
that will be cool.
But you know,
what you're doing is basically like,
and you're setting
these animals up to die and they walk
around eating grass and you come along
and you choose when to kill one.
This is it like that more than it is
like wild hunting because you know that
the,
there is no mystery as to whether there.
It's like a stock pond.
They're there.
So it's just about going out there and
getting them in a completely natural
way,
but before you come along and get them,
that animal is doing what it would do
in,
you know,
a hundred years ago,
a thousand years ago,
2000 years ago.
It's living a natural life.
It's just living in a natural and it's
going to have to do with predators.
I mean if you have a large piece of land
like that,
you have mountain lions period.
You have wild pigs period.
And both of those eat babies,
believe it or not,
coyotes,
they eat baby pigs or a baby deer.
So they deal with probation.
It's really a,
a,
a contained ecosystem.
And so we're talking about that.
That's the preliminary stages,
but I think that's the future pitches
can be big.
We're bringing you crazy shit.
Go to [inaudible] dot com o n n e t and
use the code name Rogan and save
yourself 10 percent off any and all
supplements that does not apply to the
fitness equipment because we sell that
shit is cheap as is humanly possible to
send kettle bells and battle ropes and
shit like that through the mail.
Um,
extreme kettlebell cardio DVD.
That's one of the,
uh,
the workouts that we've been carrying as
well.
And we're eventually gonna.
Make our own DVD.
Yeah.
Because big.
Yeah,
we need to do that.
But this,
this one right now is excellent.
I use it.
Go there.
Check it out on a.com.
Codenamed Rogan.
Save yourself 10 percent Brian.
Cue The music.
Okay.
The Joe Rogan experience
Joe Rogan podcast
one day Roy Mcdonald is to ask me,
man,
why is my voice off fucking distorted?
How come you let Nick Diaz talking his
regular voice?
We fucked my voice up sideways.
Son
[inaudible].
Why do you do that to him?
Good.
I'm trying to hurt his feelings.
Whoa.
I can't believe you went there.
I can't even believe you went there.
And good luck.
So what's up buddy?
What's going on,
Bro?
Yeah man.
It's always good.
The weird thing,
the pause,
the commercial,
the commercial and then the music and
then they start talking part.
Yeah.
That's the most efficient way to do it.
So that's why
everything's been good,
man.
It's been a.
it's been a hell of a run Exxon.
It's been super exciting.
I've been really exploring some of the
more non psychedelic adventures in my
own life.
That had been pretty,
pretty cool.
Some of those things.
Well I guess you'd say non plant based
experience is really focusing on
deepening meditation.
Learned a really cool thing called
shamonic breathing,
which I was totally skeptical about.
Have you ever heard about that?
Now what is that?
All right.
So basically what you do is you create
these really powerful breaths and
consecutively through notes like that.
So you're hyperventilating and you have
it's best to do this with a guide
because I didn't really know what expect
going through.
I was just like,
alright,
whatever.
They put on some music and they get you
fired up and they're like,
give it hell.
Do it.
Like you're fighting for something great
in your life and they get you kind of
stoked on this and you start breathing
and what you're trying to do actually is
create a state where you're,
you know,
you're purposefully hyperventilating
yourself,
which is actually manipulating your Ph
and then constricting some of the blood
vessels that go to your go to your
brain.
So you're creating choking yourself.
Yeah,
little bit,
a little bit out of her erotic fiction a
little bit.
So what you're trying to do is like
Aldous Huxley would say,
is you're trying to obscure the
cognitive filter for long enough that
your brain allows little gaps.
It's like opening the blinds in your
brain a little bit so that the rational
mind goes away and it allows whatever
else that is even pressfield would call
it the muse,
you know,
psychedelic people would call it source
or the other,
whatever you want to call it.
That other information that comes in
that isn't quite just produced by
irrational mind.
And by shutting off a few of the valves,
it's actually kind of.
It feels like you're opening the blinds.
Well,
again,
I was totally skeptical.
I've obviously done some of the most
significant plant medicines in the
world,
so I was like,
what is this shit?
This is just breathing.
But I got into it and the first thing
that happens about 10 minutes in as you
experienced what's called tetany,
they call it and that's where you like
get really kind of curled up and you
feel like you're,
you're,
you have like the claw,
like you can't stretch out your fingers.
Super uncomfortable position with.
They're like,
keep breathing,
keep breathing.
And I was like,
fuck it.
I'll go through it,
you know,
I'll,
I'll see what's at the end of this
rabbit hole.
And then I did and I pushed through that
state and about 15 minutes in it turned
full psychedelic experience and it was
awesome.
It was cool as shit in 15 minutes then
15 minutes or just heavy crazy bravery,
creativity and you,
you like,
how long do these breaths there fast?
Give me a couple of giving up on right
now and just keep doing that for 15
minutes and you can alternate it.
You can alternate doing like little
short ones like you know,
but basically putting out a massive
amount of breath and then it's also,
it's best to do this with somebody
they're leading because it does create,
you get really kind of a.
it's a weird state.
You're being,
you're actually really generating a
psychedelic state so we get in there 15
minutes and it was cool.
It's not like the dmt experience which
has this what they call the
chrysanthemum have all these colors and
for Texas and lights and the flotillas
then I'll all the shit I've previously
described,
but it's very focused like the vision
that you get.
And I had a whole,
me personally,
I had like a whole background that kind
of came in.
It was kind of like a seamless eternal
background.
Three hundred and 60 degrees and then I
saw myself come in but I was like
faceless and I was looking and let your
eyes open or closed.
Closed.
Yeah.
You can't really see.
If you try to open your vision,
you're a little dizzy,
you're distorted.
You've basically hyperventilated the
shit out of yourself.
So.
So when your eyes closed and you're
seeing this,
and then the most powerful,
transformative moment for me was when I
actually,
for the first time,
out of all the medicines I've ever done,
I saw a visual depiction of what I
believe my God self,
my soul,
my spirit self was,
you know,
in the Boga experience.
That was my true self.
And I heard it talking to me while I was
taking the above at.
That was the one guiding me through with
a blinking cursor going through all the
information in my life.
That voice,
I actually saw it pictured and depicted
in the physical form.
In that vision,
did it look like it didn't,
is that safe for your lungs or your
brand?
So it was developed by a,
by this Guy Stanislav Grof.
And he developed it when acid became
illegal,
he's like,
we got to create a state that's legal.
Now that acid is illegal because that
was his favorite.
So He created this and they've done
quite a bit of study.
Um,
it felt,
you know,
intense,
but you felt really strong and good
after it was done.
So.
And I've looked around at some of the
studies and a couple of people say it's
not good for you,
but other people say absolutely no harm
and done.
So do your research on that.
Make sure that you're comfortable with
what it's doing to your body
about the idea.
Why would I.
I'm confused as to why it would be bad
for you while you're doing this.
Breathing heavy.
But yeah,
it really,
you're not adding any kind of size.
The same kind of thing is it is to a
certain degree,
except this is actually temporarily
restricting some blood flow.
But it's not like,
how is it doing that though,
by just breathing?
Yeah.
So some mechanism with the Russian.
You're going to have to faster,
harder in through the nose,
out through the mouth.
This does not make for a good podcast
because this could take like 10 minutes.
I could take a while,
especially for dropped down to five,
but uh,
but it manipulates the carbon dioxide
level in your blood.
You're expelling more carbon dioxide,
which raises your Ph level.
And by raising your
Ph level,
it's somehow restricts some of the blood
vessels which creates this state.
And uh,
and really there's,
you know,
when you start to look at the mechanism
of action,
a lot of psychedelics,
what it's doing is it's shutting off
certain portions of the brain and that's
what people know.
That's where I really appreciate Aldous
Huxley's view on this,
which is a lot of people think the
psychedelic experience is adding
something to you.
Like adding an experience on.
He's saying all you're doing,
you're not adding shit.
You're taking away your mind and by
taking away your mind you allow what's
already there to come through.
And this is a reliable legal self
mechanism for getting there.
And it was pretty cool.
So I have to say,
where does the average person find a
guide to do this?
Yeah.
I would just look at Google,
your city,
whatever it is all fucked up.
You got to be careful guys.
Gonna fuck you is gonna.
Yes.
Shamonic breathing.
You've got to breathe through my day.
You have to be careful wherever you go.
You have.
Be careful with Iowasca Maestros.
You have to be careful with a bogus
shamans.
All of these people.
It's true.
Put them through your shit last.
No,
you never know because just because
someone says they're in a bogus shaman
doesn't mean anybody could say that now.
I mean anybody could say they're in
Iowasca Arrow.
You have to find out whether that's
unfortunate.
That's one of the unfortunate aspects of
being able to communicate.
We can also lie.
It's like a life coach and we're going
to say that they're a life coach now.
That's ridiculous.
She's got a funny life coach story that
they tell you.
That guy who bangs older rich chicks.
No,
I did.
I mentioned him on the podcast before,
but it's like when you're around someone
and you just immediately go,
oh great,
there's a fucking.
There was a coyote in the chicken coop
and I'm watching all these poor old
ladies hang around with this,
like super charming man with a ponytail
and I want to smack them because I'm
like,
I know what you're doing.
You fuck.
And he's hanging out with these older
broads and he started out as like a
manny,
you know,
a male nanny.
And my friend who lived next door,
I was like,
that fucking guy away from my wife,
man.
Like he,
like he had a thing about him and this
guy's not very jealous.
So I was like,
hmm,
interesting.
So then it turns out he starts banging
the wife and they get a divorce.
And so
the husband knew it,
the husband leaves,
now this guy is banging the wife who's
rich of course.
And now he becomes a life coach.
He's not a male nanny anymore,
he's a life coach.
And I'm like,
this guy is just a straight con man.
He's just a straight con man who moved
into this neighborhood and started
wearing thumb rings,
knee high leather boots,
and the ponytail,
you know,
tries to,
can only permit yourself one or the
other.
Really?
Yeah.
He's one of those
sky's where,
you know,
you'll catch him reading a classic.
Oh,
it just happened to be reading Kerouac
here.
Come on in.
You know,
he's like cultivating this whole image
and using it to scam these older ladies.
It's really interesting how obvious it
is to like,
who's she talking to?
The Guy,
he just oozes bullshit.
Button bodies.
Thirty six and he's got a cock and you
know,
these 50 year old women,
I can't believe he's banging me and
boom,
next thing you know,
he's a life coach.
Life fucking life coach.
Got to get your bolt.
Bullshit detector out.
If I'm strong,
hone that in.
And ladies,
guys with thumb rings.
Come on now.
What is that guy doing with a fucking
thumb ring on?
Silly Bitch.
That's ridiculous.
Agreed.
He's banging you.
You're 50 and he's got a thumb ring.
Rod,
ponytail.
Run.
Yeah,
ponytail.
That Paul Rudd movie about Elysium.
And what was that one about?
What?
There's this Paul Rudd movie that was
kind of a bit of a spoof on a,
on like a commune where everything was
super spiritual guy,
but I saw the ads for the last
wanderlust is the name of it.
Yeah,
main guy.
It was pretty funny.
Yeah,
there's some super funny
part was that movie vanished.
I didn't have a fucking God damn.
It wasn't.
It wasn't great,
but it was okay,
but they have a guy like that ponytail,
thumb rings,
plays the guitar really soft,
and then he ends up trying to fuck
polaroids girlfriend
course.
Of course.
That's what those guys do.
I know another guy who will remain,
remain nameless police,
very shamanistic in nature and really
trying to just bank chicks,
but there are good ones.
There are good ones.
Well for sure.
The experience is,
you know,
I had a conversation with David Cho
about this yesterday where I said that
if you took dmt or silicide been or
whatever and someone said to you,
did you just go to [inaudible] dot com
and we're gonna get off,
get off that.
Look at these messages.
I don't want to see the messages,
man.
If you,
you know,
a lot of people like look at any sort of
a psychedelic experience and they say,
Oh,
you're hallucinating,
you're just hallucinating.
But my take on it is kind of whether or
not it's real.
Whether or not you could take it and put
it in a bag and put a zip lock on it and
set it on a scale and measure it your or
whether or not it's illumination.
The exact same experience happened.
Whether you think that you are in
another dimension communicating with
intelligent entities or these chemicals
are fucking with your cerebral cortex
and forcing your visual input to get
fuck sideways by all this additional
shit that's not supposed to be there and
so you have hallucinations.
Either way,
the same thing is happening to you.
If you took magic fairy dust and were
transported into an impossible,
strange land where the sky was filled
with everchanging geometric patterns
that are made out of love and
understanding and they're coming down to
you and telling you everything that you
already know about yourself and telling
you that they love you or you're
hallucinating.
Isn't in the same thing happening.
The same thing is happening to your
eyes.
brain and the same thing is happening.
For you to sit back and to sort of
interpret and try to incorporate into
your view of the world,
the same exact thing,
whether it's real or not,
so we get caught up in this idea of
what's real,
what is real?
Is that real?
Because I can hit it with a hammer and
is the air real because I can't even
touch that.
It's like,
can we measure it with modern sources?
If we can,
then it's real.
I say,
that's crazy.
Yeah,
I agree and you know the.
I've been looking at a lot of toltec
philosophy over recently and they just
dispose of that problem entirely.
They call our whole experience the dream
and it's a.
it's a cocreated dream by everybody.
They just call it the dream.
The total is what they call it and what
they say is the most important thing is
not the dream itself,
but how that dream interacts with us.
It's a completely subjective reality.
If you already think of everything as a
dream,
then you stop asking these silly
questions about whether the mushrooms
are doing this so that it's about your
experience them.
It's about how that translates to what
you're going to be,
how you're able to see the world better,
how you're able to find a deeper
awareness,
how you're able to in what their
worldview is.
Be the warrior hunter that hunts what
they call the parasite inside
themselves.
Same thing that Steven pressfield calls
resistance.
They call the parasite hunt.
That part of yourself that self
sabotaging,
that's fearful and and that's what they
say is the most important,
is getting yourself to those states
where you're aware and you can interact
with the dream on your terms,
set your intent,
use your powerful belief to make the
dream a dream of heaven instead of a
dream of hell,
and the idea that your gonna fall into
some sort of a situation where if you
have a psychedelic experience and it
fucks your head up,
that maybe you're not going to be able
to come back and maybe you're going to
go crazy.
That that's a real possibility and
that's something that people need to
consider before they fuck around with
anything.
If you have a hard time with regular
reality,
don't,
don't go doing any drugs.
That's when you want to try that
shamonic breathing shit.
Try to work your way up to that.
Totally.
Don't just take acid,
you know,
because if you take acid it will last
like a long time and if you're freaking
out,
like part of psychedelic experiences are
the ability to just let go and it's very
hard for people to do and one of the big
things when you hear people talk about
like bad trips,
in my experience,
one of the big issues is people letting
go and letting the experience take them
there because you will try to resist it
because one of the first things that any
psychedelic experience exposes is your
own flaws and inadequacies and a lot of
people
do not.
Yeah.
I think it was Bob Marley that said it
was the mirror that reveals you to
yourself.
Yeah.
A lot of people don't like that.
No,
because you're creating.
You're creating an image that isn't
true.
Image you want to project is not what's
going to appear to you in the mirror.
Unless you've done something like this,
doesn't have to be a psychedelic
experience.
A flotation tank can get you that
meditation,
if done correctly,
can get you there,
but the psychedelic experience goes with
the earth mover and it just takes tons
of dirt off of the path.
So you see the mirror way quicker to
bunker buster.
It is exactly.
It's just gets right down through.
That fucks you up all your mountain of
bullshit that you've covered yourself
with
that.
That's what I think leads to a lot of
bad trips for people.
But you also have to consider brain
chemistry.
You know,
there's some people that need
medication.
There's some people where their brain's
not working so well.
And if that's,
you don't stack mushrooms on top of
that.
I would say that that's probably not the
best way to go.
I think that's important.
Whenever we talk about psycho dogs,
we're talking about the good aspects of
it.
But then you hear about like,
that dude from pink floyd that lost his
marbles,
and
especially with the synthetics,
you know,
you'd that seemingly acid and some other
different,
um,
you know,
some of the other different Kenneth
Chemical Monikers,
like a Dr Sasha shogun would create and
his lab or something like that.
Seems fine though.
He is fine now,
but he has the right attitude.
I think with the right attitude of the,
the key is,
is to witness and allow.
You got to be the person in the movie
theater,
eating popcorn,
watching what's happening,
you know,
kind of subjectively or objectively.
I mean,
just like,
oh,
that's interesting.
Oh,
snakes eating my organs.
Oh yeah,
that's interesting.
Oh,
going down a vine,
the thorns and having my genitals
eviscerated.
Oh,
that's unpleasant.
But no big deal.
That's the attitude you have to take
during those horrible things regardless
of what it is.
Because if you don't,
if you try to fight it,
it's going to win.
Yeah.
And it's so easy to develop a strong ego
got.
Especially if you're a man,
it's so easy to take yourself seriously,
especially if you've got some
accomplishments under your belt and
you're working hard every day and you
just start thinking you're something
special,
you know,
you really can confuse the fuck out of
yourself and then one of those ego
obliterating experiences comes along and
just exposes you to yourself or what you
really are and you're like,
Oh wow,
who?
But I almost always feel when it's over,
like wow,
I needed that.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So much feel so much lighter.
Better now.
I can get along quicker now.
Yeah.
I think going back to the archives of my
history,
I remember one particularly difficult
experience.
One of the most challenging I had,
and I've had A.
I've talked a lot about snakes and
spiders exploding and all of that.
I've always taken with a grain of salt.
The one that was the most,
most challenging experience I've had was
actually a vision of hell,
where I felt completely out of any realm
where there was life.
Like there was not a rock,
there was not a tree,
there was not another living thing
anywhere around and it was the deepest,
loneliest,
most isolated feeling I've ever felt.
And that to me actually calibrated what
my experience of hell ever was,
is hell is not in these places with
demons and fire.
There's all life force there.
There's the energy of creation and
destruction.
Hell is being on the other side of space
where there is no life where there's no
source where there's no nothing there.
I mean a rock,
a spider,
anything would have been a salvation in
this place that I was,
that I was appearing at and I felt
myself at that point trying to fight it
like,
oh fuck,
I gotta get Outta here.
Make some butterflies,
appear something,
please happen.
A color,
anything.
Everything was just drab and dead and I
was totally alone.
And that experience there,
you know,
if,
if I hadn't been well versed in,
in what you know,
in this realm,
on the other side,
then it could have been a really.
It could have been an experience that
stuck with me.
You know?
It could have been something that I
didn't allow to happen and I fought and
I,
and if I would have stood up and tried
to change my scenery and touch my face
and say,
Hey,
I'm still alive.
I'm still in life.
And not actually dealt with that and not
seen it all the way through.
I had the feeling like that would have
been something that would have stuck
with me.
So psychedelics are not to be taken
lightly.
I think you need to take the proper
steps.
Find someone who's experienced,
you know,
do something like holotropic breathing,
do something like an isolate all of
trophic holotropic,
ours,
Germantic.
Do something like that.
Go to an isolation tank.
You know,
maybe we try a little weed,
you know,
make sure that you're cool with,
with like the baby steps before you just
go whole hog.
And if you do go whole hog,
there's something to be said for that.
Just diving in the cold swimming pool
without dipping your toe in.
Make sure you're with someone who's just
on their game and really on point and
can guide you through.
And you can look at them.
One of the most important things is to
look at them and be like,
Hey,
I'm not going to die.
Right?
And sometimes you just need it to be
like,
yeah,
you're good.
And that's all you need.
Like,
Hey,
I didn't accidentally poison myself
because your brain will tell you if
you're doing it alone and you get to a
bad place,
it's going to say,
I think you might've just boys and
yourself,
dude,
you didn't mind it.
Just boys and yourself.
And you don't want that voice.
Especially when you're starting out.
That's what it feels like mean.
Do DMT.
You feel like there's no way I'm coming
back.
Fucked up,
fucked up.
Yeah.
I crossed into the great beyond to take
a peek and they're going to let me back.
It's.
It's really sad that from what we know
about the positive benefits of a lot of
these substances,
that we are forced to do it this way.
We're forced to.
We were under the illusion that we live
in a free society because it's freer
than most societies,
but it's still not a free society.
The human race has yet to conceive of an
execute a free society.
It doesn't exist as far especially a
free,
educated,
aware society that is not beholden to
evil corporations.
We haven't figured that out yet.
We really haven't,
and that's why we make movies about it,
like Avatar and they become wildly
popular.
Oh yeah.
That's the closest we can come to is our
own imaginations.
He,
yeah,
there's some,
I don't know.
There's a lot of people believe that
you're going to have to cert have a
certain amount of Yang in order to have
a certain amount of yen and it's almost
like this sort of evil against good is
like what the human being needs to sort
of propel society forward.
Constant struggle and conflict,
which creates momentum.
I don't necessarily agree with that,
but it seems to be that a lot of people
are lazy as fuck and if they lived in
paradise,
they wouldn't get laptops made.
You know?
It's almost like you need some.
It's,
it all has to be difficult for us to
push further,
you know,
but there's enough difficulty in our own
minds just getting within ourselves.
Finding happiness and self love and
actualization is a fucking battle
already,
so to say that we need this external
shit just to allow us to do that is not
true.
There's always gonna be a struggle.
I'm not saying
that we need you and I certainly don't
need it,
but society as a whole,
if I looked at the human race as a
mathematical computation and I looked at
the amount of energy that's been
expressed and the amount of effort
that's been expressed and a little,
why are they spending so much energy?
Why they're spending so much effort?
Well,
they're doing it because it's trying to
conquer the world junior because of
trying to expose.
They're trying to enforce the ape
ideology on this ever changing
technological world they live and that's
why they're expressing themselves in
these 16 hour work days.
It's really that simple.
I mean why?
Why are they in debt?
Why they owe so much money?
Why do they,
why do they work more than their health,
let's them like what do they do in
there?
Well,
they have to because they owe money.
Credit cards because they had to pay for
fucking electronics that they need to
keep the machine alive.
Like if you looked at a completely
objective outside of being a person
outside of being a cog in this wheel and
you looked at it from like,
you know,
an objective distance,
you'd would say,
oh,
I see they're fucking building towards
something and they're there in a fury.
They're in a frenzy to the point where
they give up their own health and
happiness in order to perpetuate this
process.
They're either building something over
there at the height of madness,
you know,
to a certain degree and could be that
this height of madness.
The whole reason why it coexists with
this incredible,
restrict him restriction on psychedelics
and restriction on the public's access
to psychedelics that they.
They coexist because without one you
could not have the other.
If if psychedelics were not illegal and
incredibly difficult to come by,
we would not live in the same world.
We would be connected with the whole
world,
would realize that we are all.
We are completely necessary to each
other and that that vision that you had
of ultimate space and silence and no
color and drabness and being being
hellacious because even though we have
these instincts in this ego that wants
us to go out there and make our name for
ourselves,
the reality is you are not shit without
other people.
You cannot you if you're alone.
It's for breaks.
We take breaks and you breathe and you
get something to eat and watch tv by
yourself and you go.
That was nice,
but you better get back to the people
soon because if you don't,
you're fucked.
It's like I don't.
Some days I don't eat.
I take a day off eating.
If I feel like taking a day off,
eating,
it's good for you,
but I don't take more than one.
You know I don't take a month off.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that's not good and a staple of
being a human being is human beings.
You have to interact with human beings.
We're,
we're,
we're most certainly a part of a
process.
The question is,
is this process being run in a conscious
manner or is it being run and
instinctive manner that's been hijacked
because the very instincts that we have,
which we're sort of regulated by
psychedelic compounds throughout our
history,
and we removed those compounds from the
equation which accelerates the madness
aspect of the human without the bio
chemical and botanical sort of mediating
age that's unbalanced.
I think a lot of things had been
hijacked.
I think religion has been one of the
main things that has been hijacked.
It is taken our desire to connect with
source,
with life,
with God.
If your vocabulary permits,
you know,
there's a big vocab issue,
this whole thing,
whatever you want to call it,
that force that creates life within all
of us,
call it God,
call it whatever you want,
but there is a natural inclination that,
drawing towards that,
I think there's a,
there's an old myth between,
uh,
a Hindu myth and it says,
you know,
Brahma and Maya were the only two forces
out there in the universe and they were
bored.
And so mine.
I said,
okay,
we're going to create a game.
I was a female,
Brahma is the male.
Dad would not let any of them have sex
at that point anyways,
but she says we're going to have a game
and the and is like,
okay,
we'll do that.
It's like first you create the world.
Brahma creates the world.
Then after Brahma creates the world,
she says,
okay,
now you have to create someone who can
appreciate the world and says,
okay,
so he creates humans and then at that
point she cuts them up into all tiny
little tiny pieces and he puts a little
piece in each human and says,
Brahma,
now the game begins.
The game is you are going to all think
you're different and you're going to
have to find your way back to figuring
out who you are and so that,
that idea that we're all like a little
piece of something still just trying to
figure it out.
That instinct,
that impetus to,
you know,
to find what we are at the very core,
when you remove the body,
remove the mind,
get back to the soul and even remove the
soul.
So you're just that piece of life force.
You know that desire to figure out what
that is has been jacked just jacked by
Christianity,
Islam,
Judaism,
which had as a sentiment of truth,
a kernel of goodness and wisdom.
All of these things,
Islam included,
everything has this kernel of wisdom and
value,
but then it gets hijacked by people for
power.
You know,
people who have been frustrated,
people who are sadistic,
people who want to control other people
want the money,
want the sex.
They're like the Tony Montana in a
fucking priest robe,
you know,
they jack this stuff leaders to control
the people and and it's created this
massive imbalance.
I think it's maybe not created it,
but it certainly accelerated it and then
of course the forces of greed that have
been kind of a inculcated by general
society and this feeling that you need
more things and in all of this,
this is all just fueled to create really
a massive imbalance.
In my opinion.
It did need to be this massive,
but there is going to be a massive
correction.
I just hope we don't go too far back the
other way because there is a need for
balance.
There is a need for,
you know,
in my opinion,
strength and capitalism and many of the
ideals that we actually do pretty well.
Um,
but you know,
if you go all the way completely back
the other side,
which is a little bit probably why the
movement in the sixties and seventies
failed.
It was too loose,
didn't have enough structure,
didn't have enough of the,
of the,
you know,
the Yang part of it.
It just went to yen.
And the problem with creating these big
imbalances as the pendulum swing gets
too broad.
Yeah.
Um,
that,
that is a really good point,
man.
The pendulum swing and it's,
uh,
it's fascinating how every time a person
gets into a position of power,
there's a corruption and,
uh,
a deviation from the original intent and
it becomes this,
this sort of dominance issue.
Like even with Obama,
Obama has.
Look,
he came from,
if you look at his past,
he came from a single mother,
uh,
he's mixed race.
You look at them,
you say,
well,
this guy should understand the plight of
the common folk.
This guy should be,
you know,
someone who represents us because he
grew up Kinda poor,
you know,
he wasn't a rich kid,
but then he gets into office and he's
been the one guy who's attacked
whistleblowers more than any president
before.
He's gone after the press more than any
president before.
They've dropped more bombs from drones
than any president before.
So was he for his,
for a lack of privacy.
He's for infringement on your rights.
He's for restricting constitutional
liberty.
He's for changing constitutional and uh,
the,
uh,
amendments that have given us freedoms
in this country and restricting them to
keep you safe.
All the shit that we've been warned
about by like our founding fathers,
he who would take freed,
he who would take safety over liberty
deserves neither.
You know,
that's like an old school saying and
this idea that they're going to take
liberty away from you to protect you.
The drones and it's fucking Obama
Obama's doing this.
Remember that guy that got into Egypt
and you know,
they were like,
well,
you know Egypt throughout that,
that asshole dictator,
and as soon as this new guy gets in,
he tries to pass all these laws to turn
himself into a dictator and you're like
Jesus Christ and this riots in the
street like,
what the fuck did we fight for?
What is going on and what is exactly
what exactly is executive privilege?
What the fuck are you talking about?
You mean you don't have to tell us that
you knew about some crazy program where
they sold guns to Mexican drug lords.
Thousands of guns and those guns were
used on Americans,
civilians,
American citizens.
So the border patrol agent was murdered
with one of those guns.
This operation fast and furious and
Obama says,
well,
I'm just going to take executive
privilege.
I don't really have to talk about that
like crazy.
And I'm not saying he's guilty and I'm
not saying that as a president,
he could possibly be aware of everything
that's going on because I don't think
you can.
But the fact that we have some creepy
get out of jail free pass because that
seems like some shit that might put you
in jail for what you would want from
your movie hero president is to say,
hey,
this is bullshit.
I'm going to take executive privilege.
The people need to know about this.
This was some whack system that we had
in the government.
It's going to change.
But no,
they don't do that,
you know.
And in every instance they kind of push
things under,
just wait for people to get lazy,
you know,
whether it's the president or whether
it's the UN.
I just watched a great documentary
called you and me like you for United
Nations.
Me,
uh,
it's by this Guy Ami Horowitz.
And some of the things we're talking
about there in the Rwanda crisis was
unbelievable.
So basically they had the UN,
which is a heavily armed force in the
area,
can really regulate shit if they wanted
to.
They got all the machine guns,
they got tanks,
they've got whatever intelligence from
one of the top kernels.
Kim's back to the UN and says,
Hey,
the Hutus are about to exterminate the
Tutsis.
We have the plan,
we have the leaders of the Hutus,
we can take them down,
we can take them out now and prevent a
mass genocide.
And this was like a week in advance,
sending the cable,
send it.
Can't.
Can we do this?
Can we stop this genocide please?
These are the leaders.
They're are going to get this message
out.
Can we stop?
No.
No answer.
No a better stay impartial.
Better stay impartial.
Well,
what happens exactly what the colonel
said happens.
The Hutus go in,
they get their hammers,
they get their machetes and they just
run riot.
Everybody with a tootsie identification
card,
whacked,
right?
So eventually all of the Tutsis gather
at the UN,
puts up a flag and this school posts the
perimeter and there's hundreds and
hundreds of of Tutsis that have gathered
in this,
in this building and they're safe for
temporarily as the UN is there
protecting them.
And then what happens?
So the Hutus go around and they start
drinking and they have their bloody
hammers fresh on their,
their kinsmen blood out there and
they're just drinking in Taunton and
hanging out outside the perimeter.
The UN says,
you know,
what do we do?
What do we got to do?
And the message comes back in from the
UN,
evacuate the premises,
evacuated the parents,
and they're like,
if we do that,
there's 500 people that are going to get
killed with hammers.
You realize that.
They're like,
yeah,
we can't.
We can't take sides.
Evacuate the premises.
And as they're evacuating the premises,
you see this footage.
They're like hanging on.
They're hanging onto the tank,
please take me there asking them,
shoot me,
please shoot me so I don't have to deal
with what the people with the hammers
and the machetes and the rape that's
going to happen.
If you evacuate us and you leave us
right now,
what happens to soldiers?
Beat them off with the end of their guns
crews out and exactly that happens.
They roll into the school mass murder,
mass genocide.
Why aren't we more upset about that?
That is ridiculous.
What the hell is the UN doing if they're
not there to protect those people in
that circumstance,
you know,
and that's just an example of,
we pick on our own government all the
time.
Sure we have some certain involvement in
the UN,
but the UN doesn't seem any better and
it makes sense that,
you know,
probably hardly any other government is
better.
We're just more active.
Somehow.
This system that has created people in
power has created a morality where all
they care
about is power and money and that's got
to change.
And how do you get that to change
without enlightening people?
And how do you enlightened people,
you know,
I mean you can't get them to just
breathe,
come on,
do it,
and we'll get you to shut up.
Shamonic breathing.
Everybody sit down.
You got to force them to do Shimano
breathing.
They need the,
they need the bunker busters.
It's a fascinating situation because we
are in this really odd time where we can
learn so much and there's so much
information available almost
instantaneously,
but yet we still are struggling with
these crazy ape dominance instincts and
these eight dominance instincts sort of
get subverted in these large
civilization contexts of one person or
multiple people controlling millions and
having to keep a lid on this bubbling
cauldron of humanity that you can call a
country and they almost all do the same
thing.
They just.
It's a fucking power grab.
They try to protect themselves as much
as possible.
They tried to take away your rights,
especially you're right to go after
them.
You're right to defend yourself.
They want to take away your guns.
They want to take away anything that
makes you crazy.
They want to take anything that's going
to empower you and and somehow or
another take away from their ability to
control you.
It's like,
no,
no.
Society really wants to give people
equal access to information.
No society really wanted the Internet.
They just fucked up and it would.
It sort of snuck up on them and now
they're stuck in the situation where
they're trying to.
They're trying to regulate and trying to
sort of govern people the way they did
three,
four decades ago,
which is a blink of an eye in terms of
culture,
but in terms of this society,
it's a million years ago because of the
Internet,
so it looks so woefully inadequate
today.
It looks so clumsy and it's so obviously
corrupt.
Like I would say that this civil,
this culture that's growing up right
now,
this generation knows more about the
fact that our government is corrupt and
how it's corrupt more than any
generation before.
Absolutely.
Like by a long stretch,
long shot.
There's things that we know about today.
You know,
when Jimmy,
even things that were in the news,
like the Iran Contra affair.
I mean I remember that was when I was in
my early twenties.
He seen Oliver North on TV and trying to
piece this together and trying to figure
out.
Wait,
wait,
why?
Hold on.
What'd you guys do?
The visa.
You guys sold arms to Iran.
What are you doing?
Like what?
The fuck is going on.
And you did what you,
the contras and the Sandinistas.
What'd you do?
You so coke in the ghetto.
You guys sold coke to pay for guns.
Whoa.
Like what kind of government are we run
in?
Yeah,
and I,
I think so,
you know,
to go back to your question,
how do we fix it?
And I,
I think the only way is we have to
create a pandemic,
an
epidemic like influenza used to be or
the black plague used to be,
but on the good side of pandemic of
consciousness.
And I think that's one of the beautiful
things about your show here is that
we're creating a bit of that momentum.
We're catching people and then these
ideas,
they're contagious,
you know,
that's why you call it spreading virally
the whole term from the Internet.
It can be like a virus,
truth,
consciousness,
awareness can spread and we're all an
active part of spreading that.
Each person that we bring in and say,
Hey,
have you seen this?
You know,
I remember one of the things I was,
you know I showed a video about nda is
just for an example that indefinite
detention to somebody who was mild,
I don't know what that is,
a national defense authorization act,
which is a really scary act,
has been passed recently,
which has all sorts of things in there
that eviscerate the bill of rights.
One of them is indefinite detention
where they can take someone who's an
American citizen.
Then they suspect them something and
they can just attain them.
They don't have to have a lawyer,
they don't have to.
Like you don't have any rights,
you don't have any rights anymore.
It's basically just like the king
throwing you in the dungeon.
Yep.
And this is real shit that our
politicians have passed.
We've been hijacked
essentially.
So I showed this video to someone who is
mildly pro Obama,
not crazy,
really kind of APP.
Took herself out of the old political
picture and I was like,
listen,
this is a bill that he allowed to pass
and showed her all the details about it.
Basically it was a video describing
exactly what you said and,
and going through it in about a two
minute video,
she's like,
oh my God,
really?
Whoa.
You know,
and at that moment you could see there
was a shift there,
you know,
she understood something that wasn't she
wasn't aware of.
And every time that happens,
you know,
we make those little marks.
It starts to spread virally.
And at certain point I believe that it
will get to a critical mass where the
people just will no longer tolerate it
and will be the majority.
And at that point we'll have to clean
house and they're gonna clean.
You know,
the old power structure is going to
clean.
They're going to come up with some
really crazy fucked up rules.
And I think at the height of it,
unfortunately there's going to be
conflict.
I think it's inevitable.
I don't know what that's going to be,
but it's gonna get really nasty when the
movement of consciousness runs square
against the kind of Reptilian power grab
of the old structure.
And that's going to be a trying time.
But I think they'll die off or they'll
die off smoothly,
pull in their place that's possible.
And hopefully that's the best case,
the best.
That's the way we want it to be.
The way want it
to be is that the young people coming up
now,
the ones that are in college right now,
the people that are listening to this,
when they're riding their bike to school
here,
the ones that are gonna be responsible
for running this fucking crazy machine
in the future.
If,
if the whole world is aware what the
fuck is going on,
it's harder and harder to fuck people.
It's just harder.
And I think right now they're still able
to lock down enough that they can
operate in the old way.
And when you see things like the,
the NSA's idea of building this we,
Abby Martin and um,
uh,
what's her name was the other gal?
Well David Seaman,
it was his thing as well.
We had him on and he was explaining to
us what,
what they're trying to do that there.
They're building this gigantic compound
in Utah,
which essentially copies every email
that every American citizen makes.
Every phone call that you make is
recorded.
Every picture that you text someone,
so all your Dick Pics,
all those are going to be recording so
that if they ever have anything that
they have to bring out an Abra.
Marcus,
what are you doing?
I'm in Florida and did you,
you know,
whatever.
Did you fucking burn the American flag?
You like,
what are you talking about?
Like,
well we have here your emails that say
that you were on your way to Florida
burn the flag.
We have.
You get a flag he bought at Walmart
because we traced your credit card.
We have here.
You know the phone calls he made
bragging about it.
You want us to play them back for you
and you're like,
what?
And you realize like,
my whole life is being recorded and
every email I make I have to assume now
that someone's listening and reading my
emails,
listening to my phone calls and reading
my emails.
Who are these people and what?
Because they get elected,
do they even get elected?
I mean,
when you're in the NSA,
do you get elected to just get hired so
you get hired so you get hired and you
get to be the one who decides whether or
not they can look at your Dick Pics,
like what?
What kind of a world we live in,
in where some small group of people have
that kind of power with the rest of us.
I can't.
If someone hacks into your email,
those are those people can go to jail.
Okay.
If a regular person,
some if Brian gets nutty and he decides
to hack into some girl's email and
starts reading her emails that she could
find out about that and she could have
him arrested and he can go to jail.
You can do like cyber terrorism.
You could do time for that,
but if the NSA says it's okay and that's
your Gig and you press that button which
says,
record all our micro markets as emails.
That somehow is okay.
That that's insanity,
that that is the height of insanity.
We're not talking about criminals here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're talking about the entire
population of the United States.
Wrap your head around that,
you know,
innocent until proven guilty.
Yeah.
Not so much.
The idea is they're going to record all
of your shit,
but don't worry,
they won't send your Dick pics out as
long as you keep it.
Now imagine a scenario where what makes
this particularly vial is the fact that
there's so many unjust laws.
I mean,
if every law was perfectly just and
based upon harming somebody else,
then it would be like,
yeah,
what are they going to fucking catch me
for?
You know,
whatever it's going to be like the only
people who would get caught with the
murderers,
rapists,
people like that.
But because there's so many unjust
bullshit laws like these laws around
your own,
you know,
personal freedoms,
like whether you want sexual freedoms,
um,
you know,
what you ingest in your body,
what kind of,
you know,
whether you want to smoke weed or
whether you wanted whatever.
All of these unjust laws give them so
much more leveraged.
It's like the church saying that,
you know,
masturbating and sex is a sin.
Well guess what?
You got a whole bunch of fucking centers
then and then once you have sinners then
you can manipulate them with guilt,
you know,
and then you can manipulate them with
absolution and you can control them.
But if they didn't do that,
if the church was like,
yeah,
you just have to be a good person and
try your best and you're not a sinner,
you know,
it'd be like,
oh sweet,
I qualify.
So the lighter church and they'll put
the bullshit of the cycle of evil and
this is where it gets really screwy is
that there's a good percentage of our
prisons that are private,
which means they're businesses that
profit fit
off of people being in jail.
And so they and the prison guard unions
lobby to make sure that there's more
laws that they can use to lock you up
and fill their prisons to make money.
So it is essentially legalized slavery.
And there's a lot of those laws,
especially when it comes to the drug
laws that absolutely make no fucking
sense.
They're not based on science.
They're not based on what we know about
the human body in 2013,
especially like marijuana laws and no
ways that based on anything rational in
in any way,
shape or form yet it's still federal law
and they can take you and throw you in
there magic box where you make them
money and they want to do that and
that's legal.
That's.
That's a strange thing.
That is a very strange thing to be
operating like that in 2013 that people
are making money off of locking people
up.
Some of like the guy in Montana,
there's a famous story of a gentleman
who was in jail because he had guns as
well as medical marijuana and they pass
some new things saying that if you have
guns and you're,
you know,
you're involved in marijuana,
it makes it way worse because then it
makes you like a crazy drug dealer.
Like you're one of those Mexican narco
was a hold up in Humboldt with fucking
machine guns and shit.
But no.
This is a guy that was like a hunter who
also decided to run a medical marijuana
farm because he was trying to make money
because he thought that it was the law.
He had these local politicians,
local cops come over and inspect his
plant,
like everything looks good and he's
like,
here's the list of people that I'm
selling to these.
These plants are all dedicated to them.
This one goes to this person,
this is a,
this is their medicine.
And um,
um,
I'm a farmer and I'm going to be able to
feed my family and make a living doing
that.
Now that you guys up for a possible,
they might lock him up,
Jeff,
or 80 years.
No,
that's,
that's great.
For what?
For.
Is it because he's shooting?
People have.
No,
no,
no.
Is it because he's a felon?
He's not supposed to have guns because
he's been shown abroad people.
Oh,
no,
no.
It's just a farmer.
Okay.
Is it because he's hurting somebody?
What is the easy growing something
that's bad?
Oh,
no,
no.
He's just growing medicine.
That's state approved medicine.
So they can put this guy
in jail for essentially a non crime
first in the state.
It's come.
Everything he did is completely legal.
His use of firearms is recreational and
for hunting purposes,
like this guy's not a narco terrorists,
but yet they can use all these bullshit
laws and arrested,
probably confiscated a lot of material
that they took it all.
It's always we'd his money too.
They come in and Jack your money and
your weed and what they do in
California,
it's kind of cute is because Obama said
that he's not going to target anybody
who breaks.
Only the state law said is if they break
both state and federal law,
then we're going to come after him or
rather not federal offense because it's
all federally illegal.
So he said if they're,
if they break the state law as well as
the federal law than uh,
then they're open for press is when he
first said when he got into office.
So this is what they do.
This is how cute they are.
So they don't really put you in jail.
A lot of the times what they do is they
arrest you,
they open up the place,
they come in with guns,
they scare the fuck out anybody,
they take all of your weed and then they
take all your money.
They take everybody's information down
and they do nothing,
so it's the jacket jacket that's a jack,
so instead of arresting you and
prosecuting you and putting you in jail
instead of doing that,
what they're doing more often is just
taking all your shit and then saying the
case is open and they never do anything
about it because they really don't have
the resources to prosecuting these
cases.
They really don't have resources to go
after all these guys that are running
these medical marijuana shops because
there's twice as many of them as there
are.
Starbucks.
I mean the,
the,
the numbers of medical marijuana clinics
in southern California is somewhere in
the thousands.
They don't even know how many
dispensaries rather.
They don't even know how many they have.
There are.
They're everywhere.
Fucking things and some of them are
operating illegally,
but they don't give a shit if they come
in.
They take all your stuff and they take
all your money and some people you know,
do a little time here and there,
but for the most part for like really
egregious things,
we'll do a little time here and there
for most parts.
Jacking.
Yeah.
You know,
it's for people who,
you know,
aren't sympathetic to the marijuana
cause,
which I don't know if anybody listening
to this show isn't sympathetic to that
cause,
but presuming there were,
you can take the cars out to the Ra,
the whole raw milk.
You know,
you can take that out too.
That I watched a documentary called
farmagedden.
Same thing,
gunned know agents with guns going in,
locking up yogurt,
freezers,
yogurt,
and then jacking these farms.
There's like little farms they're
selling to people.
You got these kids saying,
oh my asthma was way better when I was
drinking the whole milk.
Raw milk is.
It's obviously way better for you all.
I'll a lot of this lactose intolerance
and stuff.
It's because of the way that they
homogenized,
pasteurized and processed the milk,
which is great if you're dealing with a
city and you have to store milk for
weeks in advance.
It is certainly more healthy than
getting people raw milk that goes bad.
Then everybody gets sick and that can
happen too.
So I see why it was invented.
But the idea someone could have a source
where they could be.
They could get raw milk and they can get
it from a farm and that farm sells it to
the supermarket.
You know,
it's all safe and fresh.
It's dated,
it's all good,
but that's illegal.
That.
And not only that,
they'll arrest you with guns.
Guns drawn.
Yeah.
I guess what would happen though,
if the government didn't come in and
regulate that,
well,
you know,
consumers would start to look for,
hey,
do I want this milk or do I want this
milk?
And you start to identify brands or
there'd be consumer watchdog services
that came up and said,
hey,
these milks are good.
These milks or sketch,
you know,
don't drink these milks and the system
would self correct itself and instead of
locking people up,
it taking away whole stashes of yogurt.
Sandwiches work.
Yeah.
And what?
Where's the system in effect for the
pharmaceutical industry?
How many fucking people drop dead every
year for Oxycontin's and what?
Why aren't they beating down their door
with guns and trying to figure out what
the fuck's going on here?
No,
no.
Then the too busy arresting farmers for
bad yogurt,
right?
God dammit.
And by bad yogurt we mean good yogurt.
Yeah,
by Delicious Yogurt.
It's a strange thing man.
We have a strange world and it's a,
it's,
it's all going through a growth phase.
It's like a 16 year old is throwing
temper tantrums because they about to
become a grownup and they're not quite
there yet,
but they're fucking think they are.
I'll fucking tell you bitch,
you know,
and they get crazy.
It's,
it's real weird.
It's really weird to be a part of.
And you know,
the fact that you have the government
telling you what is good for you and
what is not good for you.
It kind of removes people's
responsibility to take the onus on
themselves to say,
Hey,
I'm going to go out and procure what's
good for my body.
A lot of people just blindly trust like,
oh yeah,
the FDA says it's good.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
that's good.
It's FDA approved
one source than a government resource at
this point in time.
There should be,
instead of a government resources should
be consumer based resources that are
more effective because they're motivated
by something other than just having a
job.
It's something they have a passion in
what I don't believe in.
Whenever you have a government agency
like that and like God who gets that job
is,
I mean,
are you sure that that guy is really
fucking into making sure that yogurt
safe or is he just some asshole with a
job?
You know?
And
you never know.
And it could be even good people in that
system.
They have to enforce bad laws.
These people in all of these
organizations,
they could very well be good people and
you hear stories of them just saying,
look,
I just couldn't take it anymore.
You know,
I'm having to enforce bad laws that come
in with a positive ideal in every one of
these bodies,
but just the system is designed to force
them to enforce messed up laws and
that's,
that creates a problem.
But,
but going back to what I was saying
that,
you know,
when someone's telling you what to do,
you don't take that onus on yourself.
I think it's really.
They think everybody thinks that it's
really helping people,
but ultimately the only person that can
decide what is good or bad for you.
You know,
the only person that decide what's good
for Joe Rogan,
Joe Rogan,
you know,
you got to do the research,
got to figure it out and figure out
what's good for your body.
You know,
you are a really cool analogy that I
just recently heard.
You know,
we have millions of different cells in
our body.
We all know that and if you think of
those cells is individual life forms.
Then we have millions of lifeforms that
are under our control and doing our
bidding.
Thank Leslie.
They just go to work everyday and do
what they're supposed to do for us and
we are like their God.
We are their rulers.
We control their life and death.
We can make their life difficult or we
can make their life good.
We have feeding.
I'm shit.
We are the gods of our body and you can
almost say they work so hard and so well
for us that they could almost say they
pray to us,
you know,
whatever analogy you want to use,
they're there for us and what do we do
for.
Yeah,
exactly.
The coffee's probably not nearly the bad
thing that we do to them,
but yeah,
that makes it.
That makes an impact.
Cigarettes.
Cigarettes should the bad processed
foods that you get.
No Green,
no vegetables.
We come from the earth.
We got to put a little bit of that back.
Know,
put some real fuel back in there.
It's one of the things that people
neglect more than anything.
The nutrition and health and exercise.
I mean,
I've obviously,
I've had intelligent friends that laugh
that mock me for working out,
you know,
they think it's beneath them.
I'm like,
okay,
by being lazy,
you're,
you're limiting the quality of your life
and you think that that's smart.
I think he's just being lazy and you
just sort of justifying it with this
like,
you know,
silly attitude.
The silly hipster like attitude.
There's nothing would ever gives a shit.
You can do it anyway,
you know,
that kind of.
Yeah.
To live like that or they discredit the
value of it,
but it's not just about physicality.
It's about what that does for your mind.
Yes.
The confidence in certain situations,
the ability to have that,
to take care of yourself as a man,
as a woman,
as a human being,
you know,
if it messes,
it changes your mental dynamic.
He certainly does and I,
I also think that your mind functions
better.
I mean,
you can have a really brilliant person
that doesn't take care of their body,
but man,
would they be even more brilliant if
they did take care of their body?
I think they would.
I think the amount of emphasis that you
put on your mental function can be
delayed or retarded by the fact that
your body's not keeping up or that your
body's sending shitty signals so your
body's tired all the time he bought.
He needs naps all the time.
Your body is breaking down.
It's always getting sick.
It's always that that derails the
quality of your thinking.
Totally.
Unquestionably,
and having excess stress in your mind
rose,
the quality of your thinking as well,
because you,
you're,
you're quicker to pull the trigger.
You quicker to yell.
You're quicker to be upset about things.
You're.
You're not in control of your vehicle.
Right?
Silly pitches,
right?
Yeah.
People need martial arts band.
That's what I say.
I say we need to teach them in fucking
school.
I think kids,
every kid in school,
it should be something learn like
English.
You should learn martial arts and it
should be in grade school,
Middle School,
high school,
College.
I really think so.
I think there would be way less,
way less.
I think the.
It's,
it's one of those weird things where
people think that it would create
bullies,
but I think it would be just the
opposite.
The opposite.
Yeah.
The discipline,
self respect to get.
And if you're doing something like
Jujitsu now,
pure striking stools can create some
massive egos.
We've seen that,
but you know something like you did,
so it's very difficult to create a
massive,
disproportionate ego in that,
you know,
unless there's some cases where
someone's just so good that they just
beat everybody and then they get to be a
dick.
I guess.
Especially if it's like one of those
kids that grows up quicker than the
other kids are like super fast twitch
muscle fibers.
Yeah,
that's possible too.
But I think man,
it would cut down on so much if more
people had that kind of a discipline in
your life.
We're trying to fix the world.
Somebody.
I had somebody on the podcast once and
we were talking about kettlebells,
battle ropes,
shit like that,
and the guy goes,
are you making a fucking army?
Like what's going on here,
man?
He'd getting people to work out and take
vitamins and shit,
and then you.
Then you tell them the propaganda's
bullshit and they need to go on.
No,
we're not making it an army,
but you can make your own army.
You could follow our advice,
make your own shit.
I'm on fucking army.
No time for that.
Can't even say that.
You say you're making an army.
The NSA light goes off,
blue light goes off.
We're creating consciousness.
We're creating a consciousness epidemic.
It's going to be like the.
I Dunno,
I don't know what color his left in
these plagues.
So that's the thing.
That's a funny thing.
I was just thinking about.
You have these analogies of horrible
destructive things happening on a large
scale,
but what's like the nuclear bomb of
goodness,
like nothing exists.
Blowjobs in the nuclear bomb.
Oh goodness.
All right.
It's all a gift.
Yes.
You're not giving anything back just
coming to you,
but it only happens on a one on one
basis.
It would need to be a massive 500,000
person at a time blow job and if there
was something they could do that,
that would become the analogy.
Do you think that this shamonic
breathing thing is something that could
be taught?
Like in classes like yoga classes,
we can get a bunch of people to
experiencing it together?
I do.
I think if people were willing to
explore,
I think you'd have to stay.
I think that's one method.
I think isolation tanks or another
method.
I think a lot of these methods need to
be explored and proliferated throughout.
You know,
throughout our consciousness as a tool,
you know,
it needs to be taught like,
hey,
you want to get back in touch with
something that's a little more real,
that's a little bit deeper in yourself.
That's not clouded by all of the voices
of the dream is the toltec say,
or our emotions and our needs and our
wants and when all this crap that's
going on in our head,
you want to tap into something a little
deeper,
a little more real,
a little more connected to your fellow
life.
You know,
this is one method.
This is another method,
you know,
and then,
hey,
maybe for
some of you,
here's some other things that totally
obviously you know,
we believe should be legal like
mushrooms and then get it down to a
science where you know exactly how much,
what your dose is.
Maybe go on a stale,
get your,
get your accurate biometrics combined
science with shamanism to create
reproducible results and an experience
that's not clinical but not entirely
just on the fringe of spirituality as
well,
and I think you could really affect
people's consciousness doing it in that
way.
What's the laws on sending people down
to Peru or Brazil or to do Iowaska
ceremonies?
I think
far as I understand it,
you abide by the laws of the country
that you're in.
You know their federal.
There's no
federal jurisdiction.
True anymore.
I think there's been new regulations
that have been passed that say that if
you do illegal things and other
countries that you can be prosecuted
farm here in America.
And I think.
Yeah.
And I think the idea behind that,
I think that what the use was
pedophilia.
I think it was one of the things that
they use to sort of sneak that thought
go into Thailand,
which I agree with 100 percent.
Not that I agree with pedophilia.
That's not what I said.
You Fox.
What I,
what I said was that I agree that yeah,
you should prosecute people for doing
that.
Prosecute people that are doing that
anywhere.
It doesn't matter if it's legal or not,
that's a fucking crime on humanity,
but the fact that,
uh,
you,
they might be able to use that against.
You never heard of a case of that
actually coming.
Yeah,
that's the problem.
It's like the laws that are in place,
you know,
especially with the NDA,
there's no been no cases of that either
and you can't really
be prosecuted for doing a past substance
either.
So it would be really tricky to try and
prosecute someone past substance,
like saying like if someone says,
if someone says,
yeah,
I did acid,
you know,
a year ago,
that is not prosecutable.
Dan would be fucked.
Well No,
only yeah,
right.
From then before the.
I think there would have to be
grandfathered in.
Right?
Yeah.
Because it'd be interesting this new
law,
like if you went there now and they
found out that you did marijuana and
Amsterdam month ago,
would they be able to prosecute you?
I don't think so.
Someone knocking on the door and if so
why are you answering it?
Don't answer that Shit.
I would say that,
uh,
I would say that you can't get
prosecuted.
I would hate to,
you know,
I would hate to deter people from going
on these journeys and expeditions with
that fear of mine.
I just,
whether the laws they're not.
I think practically it's a,
I haven't heard of a case of it,
but I'd like to explore that and see it.
Sure.
That the real issue would be like say if
we decided to create some sort of a
counseling service,
we sit down with people and the decide
whether or not they're crazy or
undercover cops and then allow them to
sign up and go to Brazil.
There's a,
there's people who do that already to a
certain degree.
Um,
I don't know.
They haven't got,
they haven't been fucked with as far as
the ones that I know or anybody that
I've heard of,
but they could be just flying under the
radar possible.
Yeah,
that's possible.
The issue is what happens if someone
actually tries to do something like that
and create a service and we should,
we should explore that and get some more
knowledge.
We're just talking out our ass,
right?
We don't really know what's going on,
but yeah,
we,
I like,
I like your thinking and that's been
also part of my thinking is what are the
ways that we can do things fully above
board because we can't in consciousness
recommend people to do illegal things.
The risk is there.
The stress of doing that is there,
you know,
we're not trying to do that,
but we want to create a change and a lot
of these changes change.
Creating events are illegal buyer
government.
So how to work our way around that.
Well,
some of the things find the legal
psychedelic experiences breathing,
you know,
isolation tanks,
certain types of meditation.
But that's then if you want to take it
farther.
Yeah,
go out of the country.
I know in Canada,
even the Boga is,
is legal.
I know South America,
Canada,
it's legal.
Yeah.
And in UK,
Canada and UK,
bogus legal.
And then in most of South America I was
because legal and also the church,
the Church of Santa Diamond or udv and
always get those two mixed up.
I think there's two.
There's two.
They're both illegal now.
I think both of us both.
Yes.
So that may be another way too,
is really kind of allow people to
become.
Explain that for people don't know what
the fuck you're talking about.
So there's a,
there's a freedom of religion act that
allows you to have your sacrament,
whatever that sacrament can be.
If it's intrinsic to your religion and
there's two religions based out of
Brazil that focus on the Iowasca as a
major sacrament,
um,
and that's the union has a vigil to Lisa
does,
I don't know,
it's in important.
And then there's the church is sent to
diamond,
which is another one.
And both of them use ios because the
sacrament and they brought it all the
way to the supreme court and said,
hey,
we want to use our sacrament to express
our religious freedoms.
And um,
you know,
one good good move by the supreme court
is they,
they upheld that based on the freedom of
religion act and there was precedence
for that based on the native American
church,
uh,
claiming pod as their sacrament.
Well,
you know that Alex Grey is creating his
own church.
Yeah.
It's just fascinating stuff.
Oh,
hey matt.
We're in the middle of a podcast,
so go fuck yourself.
This is live.
Got Five minutes.
Yeah,
come sit down.
Relax.
This is Eddie Brill.
Ladies and gentlemen,
who's a good friend from the old school,
Boston days of standup comedy,
who gave me some good advice when I was
a young pup back in the day.
Hold on and he's got to turn this on for
you.
And you were the second baseman on our
little softball.
Right?
But this is my friend Dan who is a comic
sub damn would
be breaking down the universe,
but it's good to see you buddy.
Yeah,
that's good.
What are you doing here?
Um,
I'm running a showcase.
I got this comedy festival that honors
Johnny Carson in his hometown for comics
were smart in town.
Norfork Nebraska.
Whoa.
So he built this 1200 seat theater in
his hometown.
He loved it.
And so to keep his name alive,
it's like the sixth year of it.
It's pretty,
pretty top notch thing.
Oh,
okay.
So you're here showcasing local
comedians put them on that?
Yeah.
This is my.
Each night I go to a different city.
So I've been in Vancouver,
Seattle,
San Francisco,
Denver.
I'm here tonight.
I Got Fort Lauderdale tomorrow.
Oh,
that's cool.
So you guys isn't an 8:00
show.
Is that what it is?
Seven 30.
Oh Great.
So it's going to start in 10 minutes.
Yeah,
and they said you were here.
I wanted to say hello.
I'm good.
I'm happy to see you.
I haven't seen you forever.
I know last time I saw you were at the
Improv for like two minutes in La.
I said,
hey,
I just want to say,
hey buddy,
you got to run.
But before then I think it was like
Boston.
Yeah.
Lot Long,
long time ago.
But I remember what I remember we were
playing softball all the time and having
a blast and the only.
And there were a couple of guys who were
like,
we'll take it seriously,
but you and I,
we would dance at first base,
second base.
We would dance,
we would sing and people.
Matt Graham would be like,
come on,
take it seriously.
I remember small group that's seen the
Rogan dancing machine danced my dick
off,
but remember Brian Frazier,
he was.
He would get fucking huge argument.
You were out,
you were out.
He made the fucking play.
You were out.
Yeah.
People are.
There's a Kagan playing third base
that was fun times,
man,
those,
uh,
those days for,
we've,
we've talked about them on the podcast a
million times,
but when I started in 1988,
it was the most magical time in the
history of standup comedy.
I came along at the perfect moment and
where Eddie was one of the headliners in
Boston already.
He was a couple of years ahead of me.
There were so many great comics in that
area.
Is Kenny Rogers and alone?
Yeah,
I mean Don Gavin,
Steve Sweeney,
Lenny Clarke who was in Atlanta.
Kevin,
meaning Kevin Knox.
It was these killers,
killer comedians.
There was.
So Mike Donovan,
Goldthwaite and uh,
Tom Kenny.
Yeah.
A few of those guys who left.
And Steven right there was a,
there's a great documentary that a
friend,
his friend saw me to made this
documentary about that time and he's got
a lot of great old footage and they
really captured what had happened
because it really fell apart.
And if you go back to Boston now,
there's a few local comics.
There's a few guys that are still making
a living doing like the dicta already
comedy hots and local gigs in town,
but there's not this swarm of young
talent like it was.
Well,
when you.
That's why you now you go to Austin and
you know that's happening.
That's what I'm going there in March
because that's where the the comics are.
Yeah.
And then Seattle and.
Yeah,
Austin's fantastic.
Denver to Margie Coil,
she runs shit and
Denver,
Wendy's place tuition every year for
this festival.
I at least get one or two people from
Denver,
so they're legit.
They have a law.
That's one of the reasons that I lived
in Colorado for a little while.
They had a legit stand up community.
I'm like,
I want to be a place where it's more
relaxed but also has real comedy and
that's,
that's.
There's only a few places,
but Boston used to be the place,
but there's a kid named Rick Jenkins
member Rick,
when he runs this place in Boston and
Cambridge,
the Boston comedy studio or something
like that.
It's in the Chinese restaurant.
Right.
And he's the one guy in Boston who's
really keeping that city alive.
So I go there and you know,
when I do this festival,
I looked for people.
I go to the best comedy clubs in the
best book or people like Margie Coil and
say,
show me your 10 or 12 best people in
there.
You know,
they make it easy for me.
Well that's awesome,
dude.
I'm glad you're doing that man,
because we need more,
more young guys getting breaks and
chances and there's a lot of them out
there.
People say,
oh,
it's,
there's nobody good.
But that's bullshit.
Bullshit.
So many great young men and women that
are out there.
And I find them all the time and they're
popping up more and more now I think
because of these,
uh,
you know,
the Internet has created so many.
Like Bo Burnham says,
Sam.
Yeah.
He became a star on the Internet.
You know,
I met him once at one of these twitter
functions.
Super Nice Kid.
I met in Montreal and he just tore the
place apart.
Became famous because of the Internet.
Like literally someone found it and
said,
oh my God,
listen to this.
They sent it became viral boom,
next thing you know,
the guy selling out theaters,
Justin Bieber,
he's really young.
Ish.
She was 15 when he was first doing.
He's a great guy.
It's,
we live in beautiful times.
Really is.
And so every year I find 20 people,
like I got drew Carey this year hosting
and I always bring a legend like lily,
I had dicavid in these kinds of people
and then I find 20 of the on the cusp
people who were ready to rock and roll
and I bring them in and put them in a
situation where they're all with great
comics who were smart so that they're
all,
they're forced to take it to the next
level.
And then they working with likeminded
comic.
They're not working with,
you know,
some people who were kind of,
taking the middle of the road or that
kind of a hacky.
Right.
So I went,
you know,
I'm doing this audition tonight,
and the guy said,
so,
clean TB clinic,
go edgy,
smart,
no milk toast.
You know,
just like Johnny Carson would have had
it on his show.
Beautiful.
If someone wants to be a part of this,
if you're not coming to their town,
how can they get information on it or
how to be a part of it next year?
It's called the great American comedy
festival and the only reason I came with
those words,
great America comedy,
Johnny Carson,
get in touch with me at [inaudible] dot
com.
Write to me and I'll look at your link.
Is it an email address they can write to
us?
Don't put it out there.
They'll send you dick pics.
I got enough of those.
Eventually.
Do on my own.
I bet you.
All right man.
Well thank you brother.
I just wanted to come say hi to know
that you're in the middle of it and know
it's so good to see you.
Great to see you too,
man.
I'm going to come after the podcast over
a combined saying.
Alright,
sounds good.
Nice to meet you.
Real pleasure.
Alright,
Eddie Brown,
ladies and gentlemen,
my son Dan is how brother see you later
on.
Alright,
we'll see you guys.
Powerful Eddie,
Bro.
That's what it's like here in the Joe
Rogan experience.
Occasionally people drop by.
That's pretty cool though.
I liked how use doing that.
Eddie was a,
it's always nice to run into people that
were a cool to you when they didn't have
to be right,
you know,
and he was uh,
he was always nice to me,
like even back when I was a scrubbed men
of character and he's just a good guy.
Yeah.
So fun.
Happy Guy who really loves comedy,
you know,
so it's cool seeing him do something
like that man.
So are you still going to do some
standup?
I heard you were putting together this
man.
Oh man,
I gotta I got a few minutes ready.
But it's,
it's rough.
It's really rough.
I think my girlfriend is the only one
that's heard it.
She's,
she's in the back and she's covered her
eyes.
She did one of those cat pictures or the
cats like,
wow,
not this shit again,
don't try any of my material and my wife
ever.
Like sometimes I'll be writing something
down and she'll like,
she'll go,
what are you writing down?
I'm like,
do you really want to hear it?
And just like,
I don't know,
do I really want to hear it?
I go,
okay,
I'll tell you.
Do you think this is funny,
you know,
like that,
but I don't,
I don't like try out shit on her.
People don't appreciate that.
And then the other problem is then
they've heard it already and then they
see you do it on stage and yeah.
And they probably would laugh that way.
Whereas if they didn't know you were
going to do it,
like some people have said like they got
upset at me because some of the stuff
that was on my standup comedy special
with stuff that I initially said on the
podcast and then like explored further,
but that's part of my creative process.
I say something on the podcast and it's
really funny.
What am I supposed to do?
Just let that go.
No,
I got to turn that bitch into a bit now.
But uh,
I.
well that's just like,
or with gold pieces in it.
You've got to refine that down.
Peurto yeah.
With stuff.
And that's the weird thing about standup
comedy that people don't realize.
It seems like a dude's just up there
talking,
but God damn,
there's a lot more to it than that.
There's so much extra shit.
It seems like one of the biggest
challenges that I've ever.
That's kind of what drew me to it is it
seems so hard.
You know,
I've done like debate speaking.
I've done large scale public speaking
presentations,
expressing ideas.
Not,
not difficult for me for whatever my
constitution is,
but to actually go up there and have to
make people laugh,
I look at it and say,
I have no idea.
I have no idea if this will cause a
chuckle or they'll just be stone silent,
you know?
Yeah.
It's,
it's a funny art form because it's
everybody's capable of doing it in
certain like small doses.
Everybody's capable of doing it like at
a party or amongst friends or you can
get a concept out that happens to be
funny and,
and a bunch of people laugh and that
becomes very intoxicating,
you know?
But the idea that you can go and address
a bunch of people that don't even know
you,
that are expecting to laugh,
that paying money to sneak around the
back and give them some landfill and
they're looking for just the drink at
some conversation.
But a good guy to talk to is Brian
because Brian sort of got in on the
cheat codes because Brian was stand up
comedy because Brian,
when I first employed him wasn't doing
comedy.
He had done comedy,
but he quit and he didn't do it for
years and years and years and the day he
went back and tried it again was during
a UFC crowd in it Lanta on a fucking
Friday night.
Okay.
So it was a gangster and it was a
midnight show
and it's not like I had all my material
remembered.
It was like three,
four years ago since I've been on stage
and I just had to go up on there.
Right.
I got only that.
They didn't know you yet because this
was pre podcast.
This was pre podcast.
This was like,
now he has cheat codes.
Now everybody knows who he is.
They know he's ridiculous.
He goes out there and talks about coming
on.
People started laughing.
He said,
there it is.
Say you
about five years or something like that.
I can't watch it.
Yeah,
he,
uh,
you didn't eat a dick,
but you had several moments where you
licked the shaft and put some balls in
your mouth,
but you didn't,
you didn't eat the deck,
you know,
I pulled out of it too.
Like that was one of the most impressive
things I've said that night because you
had some moments where you did really
well and then you have a dropoff bad.
I was like,
oh no,
he's fucked.
And that's the hardest thing is when
they lose confidence in you and they're
not laughing to bring them back and only
imagine.
Yeah,
it doesn't ever work in black crowds,
black crowds.
Once you lose it,
you got to get off the stage and run.
You can't try to get it back because
it's not coming back.
Yeah.
I saw Brian Brian a couple years ago and
he was,
you were okay then,
but I saw you in Austin and you were
fucking good man.
Thanks like I got to give you some
prompts like you were seriously funny
there.
So it's been,
it's been cool to see that
he's got the cheat codes but he also has
a material too.
He works at it.
He's,
he's up tonight at the ice house,
but if you're going to do it,
man,
you got to just jump in.
You to jump in.
I'm thinking how much material have you
written?
Well,
I've timed myself and I have like a nine
minute,
seven minute,
five minute,
kinda three minute.
I've gotten that far so I know
well that much.
If you have nine minutes you could
probably do five minutes.
Yeah.
You need to.
Vegan material needs to be true.
I'm sure.
Yes.
But I have nothing to trim it by like I
don't.
It's funny.
So how do I turn that?
That shit.
I got to just bomb a few times.
Like,
Oh that sort of list you to read it to
yourself.
You got to listen.
Like you know,
comedy,
you've seen a lot of comedy shows.
You gotta able to sit there and
like sort of listened to it yourself and
likes.
But that's hard too,
because there's some shit.
Sometimes I'll write something and I'll
think it's funny and then I'll go on
stage and one part of it that I didn't
think was funny is the funniest part.
They're like howling laughing at this
one observation and I thought that this
other part was the really funny part.
It's,
it's very,
it's comedy to this day is still.
There's a lot of mystery involved in it.
There's a lot of.
It's a lot of weirdness.
It's a strange art form.
The challenging part for me at this
point is just deciding on my tone
because there's almost a persona that
you bring up there.
It's you,
but it's you being a little bit more of
this or that.
Like the type of energy you bring.
Some comics are kind of laid back and
they sneak the jokes in some more
intense and they bring a lot of energy
into it.
Your delivery style delivery stuff,
you know,
you bring a lot of intensity generally
in and it had crushed and killed.
But then you'll see somebody else who's
Kinda,
I guess like Mitch Hedberg or someone
like that who's like really kind of cool
planet and it's like,
I dunno,
I don't know how to play my own
material.
That's wow.
That's a good point.
I've been doing it for so long.
I've sort of accepted the way I do it.
You don't really enemy.
I very into like certain bits,
like certain bits or like more quiet
than other bits which are more frenzied.
But I,
yeah.
Now when I write material I write it for
my voice already.
Nobody here that.
Okay.
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
This.
And there's no right way to do it
either,
man.
And I've seen guys change.
That's weird.
Weird.
When you see a guy who starts off and
he's sort of Jerry Seinfeld Dash,
and then somewhere along the line it
becomes Dane Cook and you're like,
what happened here?
Like you,
you like morphed man.
They're just trying to find them.
My Shit's weird right now because I
start.
My new bits are more story based bits.
And then I go into these long stories
that have bits in it.
But then it goes into my older material,
which is more just like joke,
joke,
jokes per minute.
Where that's.
Yeah,
well that's the evolution.
The evolution is you first start off,
I think,
uh,
you try to get things out of your mouth
that are going to get laughs and you
look at them as tools.
Like there's this hammer work,
you know,
you're just trying to get it to work.
That's the first stage.
And then the second stage is,
well,
okay,
well what makes you laugh instead of
what makes them laugh?
What,
what do you,
what do you know?
What works instead of that,
what would make you laugh if you were in
the audience?
And then the third stage is how do you
get ideas across and point things out
that you think are funny.
So like as you're moving through the
stages,
the first is just sort of jokes and then
it becomes jokes that you think are
funny and then it becomes like things
that you're relating to different
aspects of your life.
And there's like stages of the
development of comedy.
I fascinated.
I think for me,
the the thing that that may get me to
actually do it is I feel like if I
create interesting enough observations,
even if the comedy isn't quite up to
mustard,
they'll come back and be like,
Oh yeah,
that was interesting that he brought
that point up,
you know,
which
is probably kind of a backwards way to
do it,
but at least it's given me something to
hang onto,
so if I fucking bomb I will at least
make them aware of some shit they were
not aware of before.
Yeah.
Well Bill Hicks out of that saying so
even if you're not funny,
be interesting.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's.
Sometimes it seems like it would work,
but other times where you're on a date
with your girlfriend,
like,
let's laugh tonight.
I want to go out and fucking laugh,
and then you go do like a comedy show
that's more like,
just interesting.
You'd probably be a little bit.
You would be.
Yeah.
Especially the kind of tricks that you
bitches don't want to hear nothing.
They want to hear poopy farty jokes.
Yeah.
No,
it's a good point.
I mean,
sometimes people just want to,
um,
they just want to fucking scales.
Yeah.
Like sometimes you want to go see a
James Bond movie.
I don't give a fuck if it's realistic,
you know,
by the way,
that last one wasn't realistic at all.
Far or whatever the fuck it was.
Shit was ridiculous.
It was ridiculous.
But that Daniel Craig guys the best
James Bond.
I agree.
He's way better than that.
Fucking Pierce Brosnan.
Cat.
Yeah.
He was the worst.
A lot of these dynasties.
I think you're getting better batman
bond together tonight.
The new spider man.
Fuck that.
Spiderman.
Twilight,
That's why you like it.
I can't believe you're saying that.
What's wrong with the news part of.
I don't even remember.
I just remember I hated it.
Is that the amazing spiderman?
The Lizard?
I didn't see that.
I was confused.
I was just used to toby.
I think tobey maguire is a good Peter
Parker and to make them all twilight.
He,
I heard toby's ICAN.
Oh,
I've heard it.
He's a good peer for her.
Someone whose name rhymes with high end
Helen,
by the way,
Brian.
Kaylin will be with us this February
first at Mandalay bay.
Me already should fear Brian Callen
Vegas socket.
We're going to be at the Mandalay Bay
events center.
It's the same place where they do the
ins and uh,
it's going to be crazy.
Oh,
big venue.
Biggest yet.
Um,
it's pretty fucking big.
It's big.
You know,
it should be fun too because the Super
Bowl weekend in Vegas.
So we're supposed to be.
It was supposed to be Diaz,
Diaz,
Diaz as an agent.
Now he's like someone that actually
booking a place.
So he says he's going to do things.
I can't do that.
I forgot my fucking age is booked.
We somehow make Columbus.
I'm in this place.
He's a,
he's got a lot.
He gets up at fucking 6:00
in the morning to do his podcast.
It doesn't such a good idea from like
6:00
AM.
You think that's a good idea for him?
He's always up.
He's up.
I mean he gets up early and tweets,
like in one hour I'm going to bed.
It's 5:00
AM and he's tweeting and in one hour the
Church of what happened now is a star.
That was the last time you saw 6:00
AM from that side,
Brian,
about the backside flights never waking
up.
No,
not even that because they usually stay
awake for flights,
so I don't think I've seen it in a long,
long time.
Years.
Yeah.
That's the Shit fucking existence.
Getting up at 6:00
AM when you're not,
you're not totally done sleeping and you
have to get up.
But for Joey he's done.
That's when he's done.
So weird.
Yeah.
I've seen him do his podcast a couple
times,
but I was still like partying from the
night before.
He's wide awake too.
It's crazy.
Gee,
here's his.
A national anthem rant.
Did you hear that?
Pull it up.
Pull up Joey Diaz as national anthem
because it's fucking hilarious.
He was high as fuck.
It's 6:00
AM going off about the national anthem.
It's beautiful.
That's a.
that's a a guy who could change the
world.
He needs to be a court jester.
Let's try to get the guy to play the
national anthem because listen to how
high his voices.
What is this shit?
What is this evening at the fucking
pops?
There's a bunch of gay guys,
but the national anthem with the Marines
and people shoot people.
What is this shit with the flag?
You got a bunch of like gay marines
playing that shit that trump.
If I had a knife,
I would throw them at you.
Listened to be alive.
Cocksuckers get up.
This is one of the planes on the video.
It looks like it should be okay.
Stop badmouthing your country and shit.
Fuck this shit.
I'm sick and fucking tired of hearing
all this shit at this.
No jobs at this best you want to go to.
I'm sick and tired of the APP and Zbb
erectile dysfunction.
Get the fuck up yourself in the mirror
you,
but that you in American people are
crying like a fucking pussy.
You're a fucking American.
Get bullied.
People coming in because what happened
to the stupid kids in the back of the
class and shop teachers get guns.
I want everybody with a fucking gun.
You gotta protect yourself.
You leave here with a fucking slingshot.
I'm 50 fucking years old.
You're a fucking American.
Stop your crying.
Fuck the NRA.
Just get a gun.
Get a BB gun,
get a knife.
Get up and stop complaining.
You're a fucking American.
That's what they should play at school.
Not that pledge of allegiance.
Bullshit.
Fifty cent and Joey Diaz coining the
term.
Get up.
Yeah,
to get Joyce's better.
It's realistic.
He's just trying to fuck white chicks.
I know what's going on.
Probably really successful.
Especially with all that vitamin.
Water money.
Did you ever see that shit that happened
with him?
Floyd Mayweather.
They had a fake feud online.
No,
I saw in the 24 slash seven that they
were boys though.
I lost so much respect for them for
that.
They had a fake twitter feud where they
pretended to be angry with each other to
get attention because they were trying
to.
I don't know what they're trying to pump
up.
I don't know what a floyd's upcoming
fights are.
What the fuck.
The idea behind it was,
but a fake twitter feud between floyd
and 50.
So much as opposed
so much of that rap game is so much
image though too,
you know,
it's,
they're just really putting on something
50 is actually one thing I do respect
about him is he actually wrote a book
with Robert Greene called the 50th law
and in it he's very honest about his
calculating business approach to
creating a persona that's going to sell.
Well,
you know,
he doesn't,
he doesn't party.
He doesn't do all the shit he talks
about,
you know,
sitting in the club with a bottle above.
He's not doing that shit.
He's back writing.
He's plotting,
he's planning,
he's very calculated in what he does and
when he talks he talks honestly about
that.
But to see him do some kind of public
feud,
it's just seems
cheap.
Seems a little cheap.
Stupid Hammond,
floyd mayweather getting together.
I mean aren't you guys both worth like a
billion bucks?
Fucking you fucking done like a couple
of girls having a fake twitter feud.
They probably watched beverly hills
housewives land,
man.
We need to get that strategy.
They want to create some real drama.
Get Floyd to fight fucking pack.
Yeah.
Not Anymore.
Not Anymore sailed.
Yeah.
That's sad.
That one Marquez punched.
Just changed,
changed everything to punches the one
that he knocked them down with earlier.
That changes a little bit,
but the end one,
the big one to put them away.
That was probably the most violent we've
ever seen a hero get knocked out because
the Tyson knockout was a beat down,
but he was conscious and he was moving
around trying to grab his mouthpiece and
you know,
the referee rescued him.
He was standing up,
you know,
like the.
If you look at like all the various
times that someone was a hero and they
got beat like in the prime,
that was the most violent.
A Guy just got completely starts.
The second one would be Roy Jones jr
when we fought Glenn Johnson,
but by then he had already been knocked
out one time.
He wasn't,
he didn't have that invincible.
Eric.
Yeah.
He'd already gotten knocked out by a
Fox.
His name to do that.
A handsome black guy.
Fuck is his name.
I don't recall.
It makes it.
Makes me wonder if that,
if that very questionable lost that
Pacquiao had had some impact on a
psychology when he was going out there,
like he was a little more aggressive or
something that he was really trying to
prove that he wasn't going to leave it
in the judge's hands.
Antonio Tarver Antonio Guy.
Um,
yeah.
I think that could have something to do
with them.
And sometimes a fighter just has your
number now.
There's sometimes like they will,
you know,
there's that thing that they say style,
make fights,
makes fights and everybody says,
oh,
that's a cliche.
And it Kinda is a cliche,
but it kind of is true too.
There's some guys that just have a guy's
number.
Vernon forrest with sugar.
Shane Mosley Vernon forrest just had
sugar.
Shane's number.
Just knew he knew how to beat him.
He could beat him and sugar.
Shane would beat more guys in Vernon
would be if they both fought like the
same guys.
Sugar Shane would win more than Vernon
would win.
But when they got together Vernon,
one twice and the way he wanted it
didn't look like sugar.
Shane was ever going to beat him.
It looked like he just had his number
and that's a strange thing with fighting
and with fighting the way mark has and
pack all lined up,
man.
They were just so God damn close.
There's like what his strengths were
sorta overcame what pack strengths were
and what Pascal strengths were,
were adjusted enough to edge by.
Mark has two in two different fights
that Mark Marquez could take a fucking
punch though.
That's one of the reasons why he's
always still in the game because he can
take a punch and then fire back with his
own shit.
Whereas a lot of guys got overwhelmed by
pack power,
enhance speed Marquez could take it,
man.
He could take it.
So that made him like extra day.
I wonder what that is.
I've tried to talk to the neurosurgeon
that we have working with on it about
that.
You know what it is about an individual
that allows them to take a punch.
It's pretty interesting,
you know,
like what makes the short circuit easier
happened,
you know,
the weak chin,
I would imagine.
It's a combination of experience,
experience,
structure,
structures,
big guys like Mark Hunt who was
legendary for his ability to take
punches,
cabbage who is legendary for his ability
to take punches,
big giant heads.
You know,
both those guys that just big giant
fucking iron heads,
but then there's all get some smaller
Mexican box.
There's a lot of Mexicans that really
good chin,
some reason not to generalize but just
seems like that's part of the program
and then some of those lighter weights I
think with a lot of Mexicans would.
It is also is a certain amount of your
ability to take punishment is your
desire to win and your drive and your
heart and Mexican fighters have always
been known for their heart and their
toughness and endurance.
Your ability to withstand a shot and
come back because you're in shape and
you recover.
That's big,
but Mexican fighters have always been
known for their willingness to scrap and
further their ability to take a shot and
come back.
Yeah,
and I think a lot of that has to be like
a desire,
a drive,
and you're like,
they're proud of their ability to like.
They're not pussies,
just overwhelming will.
They don't want any way out.
No way,
no way out.
Now looking for a way to.
When you look at the great Mexican
boxers that embodied that,
like Julio Cesar Chavez.
Yeah.
Chavez in his prime was was that
personified?
He would bite Donna's mouthpiece and the
bell would ring and he was coming after
you and he wasn't thinking about whether
or not he was gonna win.
It was.
He was definitely going to win.
It was just going to beat your fucking
ass.
You know,
he was going to India,
you're hitting them hanging,
hang them,
handle meldrick.
Taylor and him fought for 12 fucking
hard browns and with 10 seconds to go
and the twelfth he drops Meldrick Taylor
and they stopped the fight.
I mean,
it was ridiculous.
Like he was looking for a way out.
He was always trying to win and he was
legendary and his ability to take a
shot.
But then again,
frankie randall came around and had
Chavez number,
whereas he just had this fucking
powerful straight,
right.
He knew how to land it and boom,
all of a sudden Chavez was down and
everybody's like,
wow.
And he beat him twice and it was one of
those things where it's like,
this is just a dude that has his number.
He knows,
he knows how to beat him.
It's just weird how like how much you
know stylistically how much that factors
in to certain fights.
Like there's certain guys where you
could see them fight the same dude 100
times and they're never going to beat
that guy and that guy breaks his hand or
slipped a disc in the middle of a fight.
You're not going to beat him.
He's going to beat you.
Right?
Then there's Anderson Silva.
This is fucking guys were.
You
can't figure it out.
Anybody that's ever going to beat him
that.
That was one of the more mindblowing
sports events.
There's been a couple of my life,
but seeing him going to Brazil,
Brazil,
rob came with me to Brazil.
We were ringside right there.
While that fight happened,
to see him do that is just just blew
your mind.
I mean,
I've seen him do amazing things,
pinpoint strikes,
you know,
great maneuvers.
But the way he just did that,
just saying,
I don't care,
I'm going to put myself,
you know,
he,
he got,
he dodged that spinning back,
kick it,
hit the fence,
and then he goes right back where that
kick landed.
Like,
okay,
I mean you miss me there,
but I'm gonna stand right here.
And then just slip them.
Oh my God,
God.
It was what he was like operating on.
Not just one level but several levels
faster than Stephan Bonner where he
could just move away from anything
bonded through any punch that he threw
he could roll with.
It's like he,
he had such faith in his reflexes and
his skill of,
of defense and avoiding things that he
literally backed his body up to the cage
and allowed to do to throw shots at him.
I've never seen,
never seen that.
Never.
And then when he decided to,
when he stopped the fight,
like almost immediately slammed a knee
into a solar plexus.
And the fights over and he just like,
Holy Shit.
You have to imagine that was the same
place that these legendary wars.
We've talked about Masashi before,
but that print,
that place of no mind that I've been
actually reading a book,
which was a crazy radical book.
I don't even know if we want to get
into.
It's called zero limits.
But one good thing about it is it talks
about getting to a zero state in the
zero state is where there's no thought,
no emotion,
no anything else.
The only thing left to come to you is
inspiration,
you know,
but for an athlete,
the zero state I think is the zone,
you know,
it's where there's absolutely nothing
interfering with your training and your
instincts.
Yeah.
And he just taps into that completely.
So you know,
his impulses are just right.
There's no nothing blocking what he
knows how to do.
And he's trained himself to be the best
already physically.
And then mentally he's impeccable.
You're
so confident now too.
It's like with every fight that he's won
in the octagon,
he's like slowly moved his way into
where he's at now,
which is like this almost unreachable
frequency.
I like all these people that are trying
to get to his title.
You look at them and you're like,
really?
You really want a shot?
That guy cause I'm looking at the way
you move and I look at the way he moves
and I'm like,
I don't think you can move the way he
moves and he's going to fuck you up.
You know,
and you know,
they,
a lot of them are talking good.
You know,
they're saying they want to get a piece
at Anderson.
They wanna get a piece of that and then
you'll see them lose to some contender
along the way and you're like,
listen man,
you got lucky.
You lucky you avoided that execution
because the kind of execution that
Anderson gives you is one of those
retirement executions where you just
step into ego.
Stephen Bond,
after that fight was flying back with
Dana White and he said he was just
shaking his head going,
no one's ever done that to me before.
I've never seen anybody do that.
I didn't think anybody could do that.
Was like,
no one's ever done that to me before.
That was humbling.
It was like the guy's an alien,
you know,
and that,
that kind of devastation that Anderson
can put on you.
You look at the mountain ahead of
climbing to get to the level of
proficiency that you saw him exhibit on
you and you go,
well,
I can't get there.
I did.
My body doesn't move like that.
There's certain physical limitations
that certain people are just.
They just have and certain fiscal
advantages that some people just have
like a guy like Jon Jones or you look at
a guy like Kevin around them and when he
was in his prime,
he's one of my favorites as far as like
unbelievable athleticism and speed and
power.
Kevin Randleman when he was in his prime
was just a.
his nickname was the monster.
It was a perfect nickname.
He was a jump up in both of his legs,
up in the air.
It was so scary.
It was such a fucking athlete and if you
don't have that kind of athleticism,
you are never going to be able to do the
stuff that he can do.
You can't move the way he moves,
you just can't.
And if a guy like Kevin Randleman who is
this incredible athlete,
dedicates himself and learns the
techniques that I like,
Anderson Silva learns and gets to that
level proficiency and timing and
confidence that Anderson Silva has and
then another guy tries to get there but
doesn't have the same body as Kevin
Randleman.
He won't be able to compete with Kevin
It's just there's,
there's certain,
there's the roll of the dice is not even
everybody gets a different hand of cards
and some people get to twos and some
people like John Jones get four aces,
you know,
and it's,
it's a weird thing,
but that's just the way it is.
Seems like he's epitomized the body type
for mma.
You understand that Jon Jones?
Well,
both are long,
long.
You know,
you find that for now you see it in
basketball,
you see it,
the sports have kind of created a body
type that's ideal.
And I think with them you're seeing it
exemplified that extra length,
that extra snap reaches huge,
huge.
Uh,
you know,
I,
I've always been short.
So for me,
fighting tall guys was always an issue.
It was always like,
was always like another thing that
you're fighting.
Trying to get.
Trying to get close to them.
Yeah.
You
know,
and,
and developing timing.
The thing about shorter guys don't like
guys like Tyson showed that there's a
certain amount of benefit to pink shorts
because they can unload these ridiculous
combinations in fast close quarters
where you can't sort of like the,
the tall,
gangly person can't really deal with it,
but the length of their arms actually
becomes a disadvantage in mma.
You see that with Hector Lombard,
who's a fascinating specimen because
he's not just this ridiculous power
puncher,
but he's also this massive,
massively talented judo guy with giant
muscles.
So it's like he's this crusher who also
has like the CIC grappling as well.
So he's not worried about you taking
them down because most likely you're not
going to.
So he's trying to close the distance and
drop bombs on you.
Did you see that fight with him and who
some are porous?
No,
I missed that one.
Oh killer.
What?
Paul Harris is built just like A.
Yeah,
just like he is.
So Lombard is like five,
seven,
185 pounds of solid muscle as is
[inaudible].
They're both like the same size.
They're all built the same way,
but Paul Harris can't crack the way that
hector lumbar can crack.
So Hector Lara just teed off on him and
stopped him.
But the.
There's an advantage to that sort of
body type,
that Hector Lombard style body type,
but I think there's a bigger advantage
to the John Jones Anderson Silva type,
but they're always be room for Tyson.
Tyson created himself into an
unstoppable force.
You know,
watching him train the old tyson
training videos are awesome.
Just how he would perfect that torque
and that slip and then movement.
It was like uncorking the most powerful
force from the ground,
like every part of his muscles working
together.
When he was throwing those hooks and
upper cuts,
the way his body was moving,
he made himself into an unstoppable
force for awhile and then you know,
that petered out,
but somebody could still do that.
There was also the intensity to his
delivery that we had never seen before.
Then the Tyson era before Tyson,
we were looking at guys like Tony tubs
and Pink Land Thomas and really like,
you know,
I don't want to say this with any
disrespect,
but there's no other way to say it.
They were,
they were lazy.
They were just guys who were just.
They,
they,
they really had no business being at the
top of the heap in any other sport.
They wouldn't have been.
They wouldn't have been at the top of
the heap in basketball like pink,
pink and Thomas wouldn't have been an
all star nfl running back.
He didn't have that kind of discipline.
He wasn't that kind of fighter,
but Tyson was so he came along in this
era,
people who were slacking and here's a
guy who it in work with me.
I get up at 5:00
in the morning and do my jogging and the
reason why I do my running at that time,
it's because I know that no one else has
the awake at that time.
I remember him saying that and he will
give me an extra inch.
I don't remember like thinking like this
guy is trying to get edges everywhere he
can.
He's getting up earlier than anybody
running and he seemed running in the
dark and he just looked like a muscle,
just like a corded muscle.
He was.
He was built like unlike any heavyweight
before him,
except like he was like a bigger version
of like Joe Frazier,
like
a much more muscular version of Joe
Frazier,
but much faster,
much faster,
you know,
like his,
his ability to deliver punches.
Like with speed,
like there's a video of him hitting the
heavy bag.
It's one of the most ridiculous things
you've ever seen in your life because
he's hitting it like a flyweight.
No heavyweights did that at the time.
No one unleashed those kinds of like
five,
six punch combinations in satellite.
Two seconds.
He was a,
he was the guy who came along and just
said,
everybody's operating at 70 Rpms.
Okay,
I'm going to go to a thousand.
See if he can keep up.
Good luck.
Go,
come get me.
Have you seen some of those videos of
like really young kids doing mma now?
That's pretty dope.
Yeah.
This is two twins out of Vegas and uh,
I've seen them hit the paths and stuff
and when I saw them they were like five
and I think they're probably about 10 or
more,
might be maybe 12 even now.
So they're approaching teenage years,
which will be here before you know it.
And then there'll be men and these guys,
they started out there.
They're a body has developed moving like
that.
Their bodies developed throwing up,
you know,
just effortless armbars and throwing
combinations and leg kicks and shit.
And their parents are super dedicated.
Their parents take them to the gym all
the time and they're always there with
them and supporting them is pretty
fucking wild there in that tap out
commercial.
You ever seen that commercial with the
two kids?
I haven't seen it,
no.
Let me see if I can find online because
it's pretty wild.
Just seeing the youtube stuff is crazy
impressive.
Oh yeah.
And that's what Roy Mcdonald Man,
these,
um,
these guys that are coming up now.
I'm Brian,
go to a Rufo brothers commercial r u f,
f o Rufo brothers commercial.
This is um,
this is a commercial that they have for
tap out and you see these little kids,
they have a,
they have Mohawks and they're throwing
punches and kicks in the air and it's,
it's,
it's pretty wild looking at it.
It's like everything they're doing,
they do it perfectly.
They're hitting the pads and they're
hitting them perfectly.
Throwing kicks,
taking people down,
doing duck unders and shit.
And they like,
their body is like developing,
learning all these skills.
And in the video Mark Coleman is
coaching them.
Take downs.
This one?
Yeah,
this is a good.
This is it.
Good smoothies.
These little kids,
man.
I mean these are like babies.
They look like they're like five and
they're getting coaching by rest.
His soul.
Sean Tompkins,
the background,
one of the great mma coaches of all time
who recently died.
Great guy like he's ducking under there.
Like this guy is holding the pads for.
I'm look at mark.
That's the hammer bitch.
That's Mark Coleman motherfucker.
He's teaching them how to take people
down.
Look him throwing up arm bars.
They're tapping each other.
It's amazing,
man.
Look at these combinations.
Nice.
Fucking five.
That's so scary.
Bad ass little kids and if it's not them
by the way,
they're just one example.
I'm sure there's a third of the
movement.
They're all over the world now.
I mean people that are really into
having their kids get into athletics,
you know,
they,
they going to be a lot of crazy dads out
there that want their kids to operate on
the highest level.
I'll take those kids.
That's why you think so?
I think they would.
They would just dance around you and
kick your legs until you gave up.
I'll just hold him down.
He would start coughing up these brown
smurfs.
They're just fucking.
Hold on.
You'd like fucking try to light up while
you're.
While you're.
While I'm smoking.
Yeah,
so I will take.
What do you think?
What do you think the number of kids is
that you couldn't take those kids and
those kids?
How many would it be before you just got
work?
Seven seminar seven.
Drove around on that.
We went over this before I could take a
thousand crows with a tennis racket.
Yeah.
I will fuck up a thousand crows with a
tennis racket.
I am a hundred percent convinced.
Pretty big man.
There's these crows at my house right
now.
That's fucked.
I'm bringing the thunder son.
I'm going to take that tennis racket.
I'm going to put one of those things on
so I can't lose it.
It's kind of like tied around my.
And I'm going to duct tape that bitch
threw my hands and around my wrist and
I'm just gonna fucking spin like a
tornado and just I'll fuck up a 1000
crows.
Set it up.
There's like the size of cats.
Yeah,
and I'll fuck up a thousand cats to give
me a thousand cats and a tennis racket.
Thousand cats attack there.
You'd be dead.
Uh,
no.
First of all,
they don't have any organizing skill,
so they're going to go one at a time,
like one of those Steven Seagal movies
where they've got a circle and then dive
in.
Then I kinda liked cats.
Don't act impacts counselor loaners and
cats.
One cat went in the other cats bug.
Let's see what happens.
There would be a little bit more clever.
They wouldn't attack you and mass.
This is all the cat would have to do.
We've seen this video before.
All right,
watch this
cat fucks this
scout.
Oh man,
he's got a fucking choking it man.
I hope that flex that guy.
Oh he does?
Oh my God.
Well this poor cat thinks is dying,
man.
You choking him around his neck
away.
Good.
Does it get worse?
It gets.
Cat's still not winning with the cats
flopping around while he's getting
strangled man.
Now he's around.
Get them,
get them cat.
And now the cat's just locked on,
his leg is biting the fuck out of him.
Get Him.
He's basically biting them.
Whereas Dick is really close
to his digging into cactus.
Ran Away.
He had to.
He gave up.
Can't get away.
Thundercats Ho.
Yeah.
If you want to get away in your cab by
the do the Dick.
That's what I learned from that video
where I caught a thousand cap battle.
Jesus Christ.
Man.
What?
Why would they do that?
And have it around its neck like that.
You don't expect it to do.
Yeah.
It was for one of those news stations
where you're trying to adopt a cat.
You know,
where they like,
they'll have like the reporter,
you know,
like this and kept it going.
Live exist.
Chicken Jack.
Oh yeah.
Out of their car and killing them.
That was part of this guys having fun.
But that sound goes.
You drop.
Wow.
That girl,
she,
she fell out of her character right
away.
Is there any more annoying character
then the news character person?
The person who just.
Everything seems fine here.
We're just gonna adopt this cat.
Just no real personality.
It's like,
look,
I can't cookie cutter sort of way of,
uh,
of,
of talking and behaving the local news
anchor person like they,
they want you,
just all your personality just squeezed
out.
The most personality you have is like
after some completely wacky story,
you're allowed to go,
well,
isn't that something?
All right,
well,
well here's,
yeah,
here's Bob with sports and you're
allowed to do that.
But you know,
other than that,
you have to act like your a completely
robotic cookie cutter type of human
being.
Yeah.
Here's why so many people get to that
black guy who got the bug in his mouth
and went ghetto.
Do you remember that one?
That's a good one because when black
guys do that,
it's perfect because when black eyes
take on the black guy version of the
white answer,
Guy Announcer,
guy from the news and then he got a bug
in his mouth or some shit and he went
fucking crazy motherfucker.
He's just screaming engine.
You find that here's $100.
It's only 100 and you think you get a
thousand watts when this lady comes on
when I'm dressing all those cats.
Just fucking crazy cat lady.
What is this?
Yeah.
She kept all these strays and she just
has all these cats in her house,
but where do they shit?
Can you imagine what that smells like?
Yeah,
that's her house.
Oh my God.
They're gonna.
Kill them is what she's called.
Look at her.
She looks like cat enthusiasm.
She looks like some of the girls that I
dated when I was in my twenties,
but now they're 60 Boston girls.
Monster.
Look,
she's all dolled up for this to really
get this crazy bitch ideas.
You think your house smells like Piss.
Hardly write.
How much litter does she use in a day?
100 cats.
Meanwhile they feel like they're in
prison.
It's like,
why are we all inside?
Do you have a door?
Can we get outside?
Can we get out of this APP?
Why do you want to keep us in this house
from birds?
Which are you crazy?
Have you heard about that?
New Species of spider that makes its own
decoys.
No.
Yeah,
that's fucking
species of spider.
Um,
it's a,
it's found in the pam bore pata t a,
m b o Pata,
pa Ta Tambo Tambo Potter Research Center
in the Amazon.
And these,
they make a decoy out of leaves,
dead dead bug parts and other scraps.
And they piece together an artificial
spider.
And what comes after it though?
Who has a jacket?
Spider.
That's a really good fucking question.
Something has to be trying to jacket or
if they're setting themselves up as bait
to reinforce is so fucked though.
I assume that nothing's safe.
I think everything gets jacked in the
rain forest.
Probably.
What?
What is,
what's safe
really happened on that Thursday here to
Augusta high school that led to Chris
Woods.
Deck contrast propped up town country as
fucked up town because a bug flew in and
please get the fuck out this country.
My little fuck.
Okay.
Got Real real quick.
The fake news.
Caster voice.
What is it?
Those people I think are the biggest
perverts because I think it's a lot like
a.
and this is not based on any research
whatsoever,
I'm just talking out my ass.
But I think if I had to guess,
I would say that that allow those dudes
are perverted because of the same reason
why Catholic priests become perverted.
You tell them they can't fuck ever,
you know?
Then they get suppressed and like you
tell these people they can't behave
nutty ever.
And they go,
they go off the deep end.
This is a restricting other emotions
though.
So maybe they're just really.
They just lose their fucking temper.
They lose their cool.
Like,
like that.
Oh yeah.
Because they're there.
So like cause emotional repression,
personality repression on a lot of
ambien.
Did you all.
Lot of Ambien.
There's a lot of ambien.
The sports world.
A lot of the guys I work with take
Ambien,
let guys in the production on the UFC,
they're always fucking pop and Ambien.
They pop them on a plane,
pop them in a hotel room like you guys
are fucking crazy man.
Ipod,
new mood,
mood,
Melatonin.
Just kind of fuck.
I forget what I was going to download.
God dammit.
I was trying to bring these giants.
No,
no,
no.
Fuck God dammit.
Oh Shit.
I totally lost my thought.
It was about a spider.
Fuck.
God dammit.
I hate when that happens.
Now Brian fucked me up by throwing up
this video of this guy.
We were talking about the spider.
No Amazon fucking things up.
Things dying.
Now.
God Damn it.
Train
of thought on podcasts is never a free
flowing pie chart where you can.
It's not a linear progression tree where
branches are floating in the air and
you've got to grab them while you can or
a where you are.
You're losing them.
I lost that one fucking shit.
Why you laughing?
Fucker.
Just all funny picture of what?
This is a catch.
Getting a snowball.
Oh,
the cat taking stovall right in the
face.
He's gonna be trying to catch the ball.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's the things you do when you live
in Ohio.
Throw snowballs at.
You can.
Okay.
Damn.
I wish I could remember what the fuck I
wanted to bring up.
Fuck.
'Em.
It had something to do with the Amazon.
Had something to do with spiders and
crazy shit that they're,
uh,
they're finding now in the Amazon.
They never run out of things that will
kill you down there.
They're always fun.
Some new shit they found in,
um,
in the Congo,
they found a group of spiders that acts
as a pack first time they've ever
observed this,
that there's hundreds of spiders and
they make big gigantic web.
And then when big shit goes in there
like rats or something big enough,
they just swarm it and fuck it up.
That's a nightmare for me.
Yeah.
Know they figured out how to act as
packs.
It's really spooky.
I think there's a youtube video of that
too.
Hold on.
Spiders act as packs.
My girlfriend is covering her eyes.
She has a massive spider phobia is
really incredible.
It's like legit,
like legit,
like as strong as any spider phobia in
any other human ever.
Does she know that?
That,
that couch had uh,
an ESA spider eggs in it?
Did it really?
Yeah.
Why was that?
Why did you have any?
I think I killed it off.
I just sprayed windex on it today.
I don't think that's bad right now.
Her back is tensing up really hard and
she's losing some muscular control.
There is a few times to yourself,
but it gets close.
I just kidding.
There's a spider.
They're just next to a bunch of com.
Brian pulled this up.
Fighters living in groups in Congo on
Youtube.
Spiders living in groups in Congo.
There's a the first video that comes up
on a google search.
It's a BBC documentary that shows these
fucking spiders acting as a pack.
Spiders.
They found a frog that flies recently,
like a flying squirrel.
They're going to find so much shit
underwater to the Congo.
Africa mighty as far as to bitch is not
even there.
She's in a backyard right now pretending
she's too pretty to be in the condo.
Walking all these spiders fight as
creepy enough.
Put these communal spiders leaving
groups of up to 1500 single giant web.
Look at that.
That's so fucked her.
She's got her head down and see it.
Whenever you want to come over here and
take to the nightmare.
Look at what happens when they get
something.
They just all swarm and oh,
they're super little rush to see what
sticks.
Maybe that math might be the size of a
fucking going for a neutral spine is
working together like this.
It makes sense here in the underworld as
whips are often destroyed by rain
falling debris,
animals charging through spiders do
loose if their web repairs at night and
I can't see me getting much rest either.
Masturbating.
Dude,
that's.
That's scary.
Yeah,
that sucks.
The fat one.
There's A.
There's a video on ridiculousness of
this guy trying to capture a giant
spider in Australia on the wall and he
has like this tupperware and a helmet
and he goes to put it on the thing and
the thing just jumps right at his face.
Bam.
Hits him right in the helmet.
That was some spooky shit too.
Or how about a spider and some cocaine?
Use this video.
Joe Spider on cocaine.
Spider with a whole bunch of cocaine.
Is it real?
That's not real and I guess he just
starts freaking out.
I think I would kill him.
Probably Sugar.
You ever seen a spider on acid?
Wait a minute.
Spider is this real brand slicks enemy
to me.
I don't think it's animated,
but I dunno if it's cocaine,
cocaine,
what is he doing?
Oh my God.
He's covering himself with sand cocaine.
He's just like,
ah.
It is that they are they actually saying
that it's cocaine.
If you had that much coke,
the last thing you'd want to do is
experiment with spiders,
spider,
and it was in a hooker's asshole.
You'd go,
yeah,
maybe that's guys got real coke,
which is just a spider like that.
Yeah.
There's A.
There's a youtube video called spiders
drugs,
which I believe they back in the day
that gave acid inspires the Steve,
what?
The spider is the most accomplished of
all web building species.
Recently,
scientists gave these tiny creatures a
variety of psychoactive drugs to observe
their effects on web building.
When given a minute dose of Lsd,
the spider's Web took on an unfamiliar
minimalist structure that didn't get
much work done when given caffeine,
the web structure was not affected,
but the spiders behavior was whoa.
Given thc the active ingredient in
marijuana,
the spider didn't build a web.
It built a hammock where it lay all day
and watch the caffeine spider go,
that Shit's not true.
That's not true.
You just fuck people over with this
information.
That's so wrong,
man.
It's not true.
Right.
I think there really was.
There really was a test called cane
spider.
Figured building webs was for soccer,
waited until the caffeine spider was
exhausted.
Then came up behind it and pop the cap
and it's asked Mr Krzak spider spider
had no place to live.
It ended up in the crack web as the
crack spiders bitch for more information
on the crack spiders.
That's so funny.
That's ridiculous.
Did you hear about this study that
they're.
They're trying to do at Harvard medical
school is looking for an adventurous
woman who's willing to give birth to a
neanderthal.
Awesome.
This is there really going to make a
neanderthal from.
We're going to make out of fucking human
being.
I don't know how the fuck they're going
to do like Jurassic Park style.
They find an old bone and they're going
to get some DNA out of there and well,
what's really bananas is that they're
actually creating a life that is
essentially a type of human being.
I mean,
neanderthals are essentially a type of
human being,
right?
I mean that's the.
That's,
that's the definition.
Okay.
They're not homosapien,
but they are a type of human being.
Right?
Like,
isn't that like Homo Floresiensis?
Are they a type of human?
I don't know.
Are they a type of primate?
We haven't had to cross that bridge.
It hasn't come up yet.
That's a slippery slope.
How far back do we still have to give
them the rights of people or should we
give them the rights of people?
We should treat all animals with
respect,
but you know how far back in the species
chain do we declare somebody assenting
it being well,
yeah.
Not only that,
what do you do with this thing and you
allow it to go into society and mate,
do you allow it to have a life?
What if you make a male and it starts
raping?
What if it goes in the UFC?
What if it goes into the UFC or GEICO
Christ?
What if it's five feet tall?
Two hundred pounds.
That's what neanderthals.
Wade and just chimp strong because
neanderthals by the way,
had bone structure that was completely
different than ours.
I mean you,
their bones were much thicker,
much heavier,
you know,
they,
they were literally five feet tall,
200 pounds and that's just different.
They're built different than human
beings.
What would that would they allow that
have to be a whole new set of Nevada
State Athletic Commission?
A lot of things in our society would get
really kind of weird if there was
another set of and b.
Did you see district nine or did you
like it?
That was all right.
I liked it.
I thought it was pretty interesting what
they were trying to do.
If you haven't seen as a science fiction
movie about this alien spacecrafts
wasn't there supposed to be more of
them?
Yeah,
I think they're going to do another one.
They were going to do it.
They left room at the end of it for a
sequel,
but it was the science.
Cgi
animation gotten good enough where they
could make a realistic movie about
these,
these aliens living amongst people and
the way they did it was pretty.
It was pretty cool about how they just
sort of assimilated in sort of became a
part of life here on earth that people
just dealt with.
The fact that these,
uh,
what did they call them?
They called them.
They had some fucking creepy name for
them that pissed them off.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
But I mean if they went a hold and went
and went ahead rather and did this and
created neanderthals,
we might find out why neanderthals are
extinct,
you know,
we might've killed them off.
I mean,
it's very possible that human beings
killed them off because we don't know
what their behavior was like.
But we do know what the behavior of a
lot of other primates is.
Like we know how fucking ruthless
chimpanzees ruthless baboons are.
What if we know how ruthless people are,
we know how ruthless Homo Sapiens
neanderthals and take it to the next
level.
What are the fucking baby and psychos
because we found evidence of of
cannibalism on a lot of human corpses
that they think might have been either a
result of homosapiens or neanderthals
prey Predator,
neanderthals going after people,
and then there might've been like humans
hunting humans in the nfl,
hunting people or people hunting them.
They also know that it was one of the
things that talked about with the Steve
Rinella.
The native Americans were rampant,
cannibals and a lot of parts of this
country for show or for me,
for me.
Really?
Yeah.
Especially the Great Lakes area.
Apparently Great Lakes area.
They were known for catching people and
eating them.
That's one of the things that's always
difficult when you look at these
cultures that you revere because I
certainly revere a lot of things about
native American spirituality and certain
things about Mezo,
American spirituality as well,
but then you see these cultures in their
peak doing things like human sacrifice
cannibalism or weird things and they're
like,
well,
we weren't quite there yet at some good
principles.
Yeah.
They were still ripping people's hearts
out to please the sun.
God.
Well,
the,
the creation of the temple of Tlt will
con is that said the Aztec temple where
they killed 80,000
people in four days.
They sacrificed something like 80,000
people.
They were all prisoners essentially that
they use to build the temple.
Then once they were done,
they're like,
okay,
cool.
We're gonna fucking kill you all now.
Now that we,
now that we're done.
So it's like on one hand you have this
amazing society that's capable of
creating such a magnificent structure
like this huge,
gigantic Aztec temple.
But the other hand,
they're also capable of killing
everybody that helped build it,
cut their fucking hearts out,
chuck and them down a flight of stone
stairs,
thump,
thump.
Next,
somebody.
I'm Dan Dodi,
uh,
one of the guys that was working on that
media to show with me when we were going
over this.
We were talking about how crazy those
numbers are.
He did a calculation of it.
It means you have to kill someone every
13 seconds.
Massive,
massive obsidian,
the city and knives and stab their
fucking hack in your head off with a
stone ax and they're killing someone
every 13 seconds.
It's intense.
This doctor has a really crazy ideal and
outlook on this to sort of justify.
You can tell that this guy wants to do
this.
This is one of his goal,
wasn't of his quotes.
If you become a monoculture,
you are at great risk of perishing.
Therefore,
the recreation of neanderthals would be
mainly a question of societal risk
avoidance.
So he's saying that it would benefit the
human race to reincorporate neanderthals
into our population.
You know,
man,
fuck.
Do you know what they're like?
They are way more primitive than us.
Where words this accepting that
physically they're way more dominant
than us.
They probably would beat us in sports.
Their bones are thicker,
much stronger.
Yet if we could outsmart them,
but here's the thing.
They had bigger brains than us.
Yeah,
but we won.
but why did we win?
Did we win because we're the more evil.
No,
I wonder.
I wonder what the hell was.
I think that's why we got to do it.
Just figure it out.
I think we're more clever than them
because there's also evidence that
neanderthals had figured out a lot of
shit that we figured out,
like tool making and fire.
They didn't figure out the Internet
though.
They didn't have guns.
Dummies.
Yeah.
I think.
I think we're on a path towards more
clever and more spiritually enlightened,
but it's a very divergent path that has
big errors and big fuck ups and big
terminal nodes that really aren't going
anywhere.
Maybe you're just going to have people
die.
Were the cuts.
Maybe we won and where the cuts and the
neanderthals have won.
Maybe they were like way cooler than us
and they were just overwhelmed them with
continuous and maybe you're all the shit
that we point to as like problems in our
society could all be avoided if we went
back to being the anatomic one.
That was the triumph of evil ever.
Get on it.
Well,
this is one of the things that the guy's
saying that neanderthals might think
differently than we do.
We know they have a larger cranial size
and they could even be more intelligent
than us.
Wow.
That is crazy.
I never heard anybody say that when the
time comes to deal with an epidemic of
getting off the planet or whatever,
it's conceivable that their way of
thinking could be beneficial.
This guy's fucking crazy.
Their way of thinking.
He wants to raise a fucking civilization
of neanderthals.
He wants to bring this guy probably
masturbates to pictures of balls.
He's probably a freaks.
This guy's asking a woman to give birth
to a fucking new kind of monkey or a new
kind of whatever the fuck it is.
If it's not a human.
I mean we're humans Homosapien,
right.
Is that the case?
So what is that?
So neonatologists another type of
primate or is another type of is
another?
No,
I think it was a different chain.
I think as far as I recall,
and this is a little vague,
but I think it was a different chain of
evolution where that when terminated in
neanderthal and another one,
all the homo erectus,
Homo Sapiens,
they all went on another evolutionary
chain.
I think that's how it went.
I don't think there's a direct link,
but I dunno.
Yeah,
I dunno either.
interesting to think about though.
And it also gets,
you know,
the minute you introduce,
especially in more advanced cultures,
like if,
if there were an alien culture that
would come,
the amount of chaos that would cause,
particularly in the religious structure
of things would be earth shaking.
I mean the whole tenants of all of this
that we are created in God's image
perfectly blah blah,
blah.
That and then you have someone who's
smarter,
Cooler,
badder than us,
you know,
and then how does,
how do you rectify that with all these
major religions?
I think that's,
that would be the biggest.
There would be a huge upheaval if that
happened.
Massive chaos.
Yeah.
What the fuck man.
Have you google neanderthal profile of a
super predator.
This is one a widely discounted and I
should say this widely discounted
theory,
however,
it's kind of fun.
Kind of fun to talk about it.
Neanderthal poor profile.
Um,
what did I google profile of a monster?
The profile of the Super Predator.
This,
uh,
this guy had this idea that the,
the vision that we had of neanderthals
looking just like us was really based on
nothing.
We don't have any actual neanderthal
bodies were putting skin on them and
recreating them with clay.
And why would we do this and make it
look like that when we might want to
make it look like a gorilla or a champ
or a profile.
Super Predator.
Look up videos,
buddy video.
Go to video.
Youtube.
What does that.
Would you put butthole or Mexican in
there?
How are you getting all these,
this mustache yet?
What are you doing?
How are you getting this?
Oh,
that's not neanderthals.
Google did it.
Cool.
Thyra.
Yeah,
that's what you need.
It's just any,
a looking mustache and a n,
d,
e r t h a l.
that's it.
Click on the first one.
It's kind of cool.
Go full screen on this bitch.
So the car,
the accepted view of what the look like.
A big hairy than us and with a lot of
those and think thicker brow ridges.
But apart from that there are
unquestionably human.
In fact,
it's been said that if you gave the
Neanderthal to shape the head count and
dressed him up in a nice suit,
he can easily attend Harvard,
although it named rich parents.
There's a couple of things wrong with
this picture.
First,
it's not based on any sound,
archaeological evidence.
That's because soft tissue features like
skin hair,
color and non preserved the undertone.
The other reason is that after studying
the end of those for 10 years,
I'm convinced they look nothing like
this at all.
I've only been remaining or throw them
at us here on the end,
the thought predation created modern
humans.
In this video,
I'm going to draw on the latest
archeological,
genetic and forensic evidence to
challenge our assumptions about what
neanderthals look like.
It looks like something we should make a
kettle bell.
You can see examples of this enter
promoting bias in television
documentaries and in museum
reconstructions around the world.
Men are sometimes showers quite
handsome.
We just want to get to try it back
there.
We and some of them,
I believe that neanderthal males so
began hunting human females mistakes
really size.
It really makes me mad of sexual and
cannibalistic predation went on for an
excess of $50,000.
Imagine if.
Imagine if you had one of those coming
after Mrs Rogan.
Woo Man.
Could you imagine if we were you.
We recreate this thing and it does come
out looking like that,
that this woman gives birth is
neanderthal and it comes out looking
like an ape.
It really tests them are fucked up black
face with big gigantic teeth and knows
how to use spears.
I think this guy is like really quacky
though,
and he is Australian,
which makes them extra quacky.
No,
there's not a lot of like super experts
that people take seriously that top
light that.
Except for grandma on the bush,
he's English,
but English is completely different.
If you have English,
you can sell things that people wouldn't
ordinarily buy.
Like cooking where if you have like an
English salesperson.
Yeah.
But uh,
but Australian,
unless you're selling boomerangs or some
sort of a crocodile gun,
you know,
you're not going to listen to Australian
dude.
He's just there to fun,
loving,
carefree people.
They're not really the right are
archeologists are the right people to
tell you what a fucking neanderthal
looks like.
At least the way we want them to be.
Yeah.
I wonder if this is bullshit.
Like I said,
this guy's widely widely been
discredited the aquatic ape theory,
which had me for about an hour and a
half.
Yeah,
that's a weird one,
right?
There's a theory.
They're wondering why human beings are
so fatty when we're babies as opposed to
other primates which come out like
champs when they're babies,
they come out and they're looking.
They look pretty rugged like right out
of the gate.
They got sin.
You.
They don't have a lot of body,
but people were like
balls of fat and the idea was that we
were born to sort of be able to float
around and water and then we lived by
the water.
We were aquatic apes while we did live
by the water.
When those volcanoes happen,
I think that was something that the
genetic bottleneck theory,
which does have some criticisms too,
but when these volcanoes happen,
if forced everybody to the only life
source that was available at the time
which was coming out of the ocean is
those were the,
you know,
the fish and the seaweed and things that
were unaffected by the massive climate
change and the,
the,
the shit that was in the air that was
causing people massive death.
Well,
they say even to this day,
80 percent of the world's population
lives near the water,
which is kind of fascinating because as
the water level rises,
if something catastrophic happens,
I mean that,
that really would leave a fucking lot of
confused motherfuckers in the middle.
You know,
if the world.
It's like say if the United States and
every other part of the world,
everything a thousand miles in each
direction was covered with ocean and
you're just left with the center of the
United States.
Good luck.
Okay.
Got dudes who know how to make bows and
arrows.
You know,
I mean for real.
If you were left with like South Dakota,
if South Dakota was all the humans that
were above water and everything else
done,
you got plenty of food.
Okay,
but there's no more internet and you've
got to figure out society from scratch,
from only the people in South Dakota.
Just a total random sampling.
That's a tough go.
Good luck.
Good luck away.
Most of these catastrophic work tasks,
Duffy's work though is the smartest,
the brightest,
the cleverest.
They are the ones that ended up
surviving or you put a gun in their
mouth because they don't want to survive
with all these fucking dummies trying to
eat them and they're like,
you know what?
I think I'm going to just check out and
see what's next.
You know,
it was a crazy place to go with Pompei
and you go there and you see when the
people are frozen and ash like huddling
with their kids within that just rolled
through and discipline just blew up and
vesuvius rolled in and kicked everything
in.
Ash,
that's a crazy,
crazy moment.
Frozen in time.
It's interesting to see,
and not that long ago either.
No,
no.
Remember Mount St Helen's remember when
we were younger?
Yeah,
super young.
That was a.
That was a big one.
Man.
That was a.
There was a Washington state and a giant
volcano blew off.
We just don't see enough of those.
They happen so rarely were like,
oh,
okay.
That's what fucking happens.
There was that one in Iceland that
fucked up air travel,
but yeah,
that was a little bit of a baby one.
Yeah,
I think.
I Dunno.
I think it has a big brother though that
when that one goes off,
then I think the last time that happened
that the water froze,
like really far up the Mississippi River
and things got really fucked.
It was like a two year winter crops
failed.
This was around like 18,
12 I think.
So an Icelandic volcano in 18,
12 caused a two year winter in America.
It's just because they put so in the
atmosphere
that cools everything off.
Can we get a big fan and fix that shit?
You'd think something right below it on
China.
Push it.
Another direction with that shine is
already making the big fan to blow on
us.
They probably got fans,
they're launching and space like a fan,
but with wings and it's going to just
hover fan with a helicopter blade and
just hovers up there and blows.
I don't think that any of these ideas
work.
Yeah,
the natural disasters,
that one thing that people aren't
prepared for that they don't.
You know,
everybody's worried about the government
collapsing.
Everybody's worried about the end of the
world and oh,
what if a dollar is useless,
which are really should worry about man,
it's fucking super volcanoes and
asteroids.
Those are the big ones.
And this,
if a super volcano in Iceland can cause
a two year winter in America,
what happens of yellowstone blows with
what happens at that motherfucker takes
off that species extinction time.
It's weird.
It's like our society is.
It's so dependent upon this state of the
atmosphere staying the where it is,
but we have so much evidence shows that
it really doesn't last and it changes
radically all over the world.
And then,
you know,
different parts of the world are
sometimes covered in ice and then a few
million years later,
the tropical rain forest and you know,
what do you do?
You just,
I guess you just move and adopt,
moving,
adapt.
Rather there was a harvard,
a biologist or an astronomer rather
recently that was saying that he doesn't
believe that he doesn't believe that we
are a or he does believe rather than
we're unique in that we're.
We're the only life form possibly in the
whole world that's like us and that our
situation is so rare with our ability to
have lasted this long protected by
Jupiter.
All the asteroids are hitting Jupiter
and that our environment has been so
stable for so long that it's allowed
this crazy explosion of intelligence and
innovation and that the odds of that
actually happening anywhere else in the
world or anywhere else in the universe
are incredibly,
incredibly,
incredibly rare.
And then.
But then you have to multiply that by an
infinite,
virtually infinite universe.
And the fact that if you propose that
other species in this virtually infinite
universe just started a bit earlier and
they evolved to the point where they can
travel,
they are going to be the ones that
traveled to us prior to us traveling to
them
and they have legal mushrooms,
obviously.
Maybe they made mushrooms and they put
'em on asteroids and send them our way.
A little helping hand.
Well,
that scene a little pat on the butt.
That's the theory about how life on this
Panspermia Panspermia with mushrooms.
There was another show that I watched.
It's Morgan Freedman's show through the
wormhole where this astrophysicists was
explaining the infinite in that the
universe is so big that there are the.
The odds are that there is an exact
duplicate of you what the exact cells
and the exact life experiences and it's,
you know,
an infinite number of trillions of miles
away.
Like if you.
You can't even wrap your head around how
far away it is.
But infinity is so big that it means
that the world as it exists today,
exactly what the exact adams in the
exact order that the universe is so big
that it could exist,
not just exist,
but exist in so many different forms
that the exact creation of this earth,
the exact events that have taken place
all have been recreated on this
planet.
There is a.
yeah,
there is.
I heard that in a different way saying
that your actions echo in eternity
because of that same thing,
because everything that you do now will
be repeated just by the law of infinity
by another you at another point in
another time period in another universe
or in the same one.
So it was the idea was that your actions
echo in eternity because those,
those impetuses,
the choices you make will be duplicated
in another experience.
And then that is crazy.
Then there's the Uber Mind Fuck decision
universe scenario where every decision
you make branches off and do a
completely new in independent universe
and they're all parallel existing and
that every time you make a decision for
the positive or for the negative,
the entire universe is restructured
around you and it's a completely new one
and that will any similarities to the
previous universe or just just that
similarities that you are existing in
these new planes that have been
recreated over and over and over again
and that life,
much like we see in when you break the
world down to subatomic particles and
then break it and bring it all the way
up to universes and galaxies,
that the universe and it's moments are
fractal as well,
and they are also infinite and that in
these decisions,
in moments,
you create infinite universes.
I get so crazy,
but the universe itself is so crazy.
Why is that any crazier?
You know,
why is it any crazier than an infinite
universe?
Why is that any crazier than hundreds of
billions of galaxies,
Wyoming?
It's all fucking crazy.
Like you can't wrap your head around and
you're like,
Hey,
I have 150 acres of Oh well fucking whip
the shit.
The Universe is infinite and what's 150
acres?
That doesn't mean anything
to explore these topics.
I remember there was a philosophical
conundrum in which the philosopher says,
I can prove to you that if I shoot an
Arrow at a target that it will never hit
the target and here's how they do it.
At a certain point,
the Arrow would be halfway to the target
and that takes a certain amount of time.
At another point the Arrow will be,
you know.
Then you take the next half,
so at a certain that the next half
point,
that will also take a certain amount of
time.
Then you take the next half point to
where it's halfway to the.
That'll take another
amount of time while there's always
going to be another half point which is
going to have a time value and so if
there's a continuous amount of time
value in the half point of distance
moved by a coworker by whatever,
infinite a measurement by that logic.
The arrows should never hit the target,
and you start to think about that.
You're like,
Huh,
yeah,
that's fucked up.
That's some hippie bullshit that hit
that target.
Exactly.
That's what we all know has never been
bowhunting.
Need to get with Ted nugent and say,
get out your fancy graph and watch this
bitch.
See Your theory sucks.
A fat deck,
because that's a dead deer.
That's right,
and there used to be in those
philosophical debates,
there will be people,
especially in the skeptical debate.
There was one famous instance where I
think someone just slap someone in the
face that you think you think nothing is
real.
How about this back and just hit one of
the skeptics in the face like that was
real,
wasn't it?
I just started fucking around with too
many.
Whatever got slapped away.
It goes.
There are too many
10 minutes.
That means we're going to wrap this
bitch up and bring it home.
Aubrey.
Marcus,
you are a bad motherfucker.
Thank you very much.
My friends coming here.
It was awesome.
Was We went on a double date last night.
That was powerful.
A good times,
man.
And,
uh,
we'll uh,
we'll move on with many,
many new things in the future and I
think,
uh,
I think this hunting thing is a good
idea.
Yeah,
I think there's something to explore in
that.
It can be revolution,
at least.
Gentlemen.
Absolutely play.
It plays out.
Well,
that'll get us kicked off youtube.
Don't do it.
So people want to check some more stuff
out for me.
Warrior poet.us
at warrior poets,
my twitter and I also put out a new
video inspired by the style of Jason
Silva.
You can get to
that@vimeodotcomslashwarriorpoetthatUSworriedaboutusorwhatisawarrior.com
bringing me giant,
a giant
video.
It's really fun.
I love,
I think the world of feeds off of
inspiration to a certain extent.
Anytime you could do something like
that,
that is a little burst.
And Jason Silva,
I just retweeted one of his day.
What a fucking great guy.
He is,
man.
If you met him in person.
I have,
I'd like to know what next time he does
a podcast.
He'll be back on somewhere towards the
end of February I think.
I think you said the end of February and
when he does,
we'll have you on with him because he a
fucking beautiful human being.
Oh actually,
April.
Okay.
He'll be back in April.
So,
uh,
we're going to have for me,
I think he's in New York City right now.
Bang a bunch of smart bit
yet.
I'm Jason.
Thank you everybody.
I know we were supposed to have rick
Ross in today,
but arby's only in town for a couple of
days,
so we had to switch it around and rick
will be joined us one week from today.
So next Wednesday we'll have the real
rick Ross,
the real rick Ross who is not a rapper.
He is a former criminal who's now a
fucking great guy and a community
activist and an interesting character
with a great story.
We'll have tim ferriss on Tuesday.
Tim Ferris will be returning and Monday,
and I know I'm going backwards,
but Monday we have Alex honnold on the
podcast who is the number one free solo
climber in the world.
He's,
if you've not seen this cat,
you have to watch his videos.
You will shit your pants if you one of
those people like me that just gets
squeamish at like ridiculous heights
when people do nutty shit.
This guy free solo climbs places where
no one else can do it and it is fucking
insane.
He climbs things that go this way,
like least off and he's doing it for
thousands of feet.
It's so hard to watch it's sweaty palms
and freaking out and this dude is just
super mellow and inches his way along.
And uh,
he's going to talk to us about it on
Monday.
Next week,
Monday,
Alex honnold.
Tuesday,
Tim Ferriss,
Wednesday.
Rick Ross.
Thank you very much to on it.com.
That's o n n I t use the code name
Brogan and save yourself 10 percent of
any and all supplements.
And if you go to audible.com,
Joe,
you will get one free month of audible
service for 30 fucking days and a free
audio book.
It's a tremendous service and an
excellent company.
And,
uh,
we're proud to sponsor or listening to
bus.
Just get that information.
Hooker,
any way you can,
uh,
we will be back in a little bit with an
icehouse house.
Chronicles going to do that tonight.
Yeah.
And also,
uh,
can I just say that tomorrow we have a
powerful,
a death squad show at Joe Joey Diaz,
Duncan Trussell,
Doug Benson,
tiffany had this Yoshi Brody,
Stevens and me at the Melrose Improv,
8:00
Improv.com.
And if you haven't been to,
Improv is one of the best clubs in the
country along with the Ice House in
Pasadena where we are at tonight.
Um,
uh,
Greg Fitzsimmons,
Brian Red Band,
a Yoshi Obayashi,
uh,
Adam Hunter and Ian Edwards and me bitch
tonight.
Ten o'clock.
So if you're hearing this in your
clothes,
getting your fucking car hooker,
making that happen.
All right,
we'll see you guys next week.
Thank you.
Adios.